e
here
okay and I got the list
online to make sure
here
good Sal's not
okay everybody's here Sal okay all
right all right we'll start out
[Music]
with 167
p on wax who wants to make the uh to
yeah okay representative wal second by
representative spear moves to pass on
wax which they've already banned baned
already and you know ski ski ski they've
already banned stuff skis so we just and
it's the same manufacturers that make
the same wax for the boats so it's it's
a piece of cake to do it yeah and that
we're just and we're just adding to the
Christmas tree
right a technical legis to the
tree yeah because we knew that when we
passed the P bill that there would be
other people coming
in
okay okay I think you were no one the PS
okay any discussion on the motion about
to pass on 167 okay so um all those in
favor so we have we
got you know all
right uh okay Pressa Cole pusk hunt
Ammon melier Herbert Spear and salvi so
all those in favor raise their hand one
two are you on this one
oh four this is oh
one okay okay uh next one is house
and so uh representative press would
like to move to that we
retain
312 second it okay um NC this one the
dust they haven't really got we want to
we want to have a uni there some point
in time we need a uniform rule policy
and NCAA is still working on it they're
trying to figure it out
and we had we had a lot of discussion on
the sections about what they can and
can't advertise and I just don't want to
get into that at this
one seconded was that uh don't no we
need well yeah co co retain I had had my
pen here what did I do with it I lost
again there it
is okay all
so okay any discussion on the motion of
retaining seeing none all those in favor
raise your
hand okay one two three four five six
seven eight no who's not her who's not
on it eight who was not on here that
just r hand okay is that eight really
eight
Z one two three four
nothing okay moving right along 434
requiring a polic insurance company to
provide a rental car for at least 7even
days this is this one is really up to
the insurance company to decide whether
they want to do this or not
right anybody here who want to tell us
434 anybody here want to tell us why we
should shouldn't raise your hand if you
think we should not pass 434 okay okay
that's pretty much where I was all right
okay all righty uh and oh second second
hunt and do you want to speak to the
motion thank you Mr chairman just like
you said I think it's up to the
insurance
companies
right well that so we don't need a build
to do that no we don't they they take it
up in rules that's true okay uh next is
454 yeah oh we didn't have a vote okay
all those of five of itl please raise
your
retain second by representative
Cole yeah so much like even even and I
didn't we get into the college students
but there's and we'll have another one
coming up that these are bills that the
actual language of the bills it's not
necessarily going to work um but that by
us retaining the bill it sends the
message uh to anybody who notices that
this bill is not dead that it's still go
live and and at any moment if if we see
there's a problem then we can dust it
off and and pass it if if it's necessary
so and that that's certainly true terms
of this ethanol
issue okay
everybody comfortable with the retaining
motion all right all those in favor of
retaining raise your hand one two three
four five six seven eight okay
along along and this was H yeah anybody
second okay
biodegradable H 5 56 does anybody here
want to speak for this
bill where are all these
sponsors say he sent me a letter that's
right he sent me an email and was hoping
he said this is It's really perfectly
really
the common sense and all that but
there's no how do we enforce it that's
the thing I I spoke to him about it and
we couldn't figure out how he said well
the assumption is somebody from one of
the uh industry standards would would
would pick up on it and and vot for it
right and I don't think that's the way
you write a bill well I I I would say
this issue and the way and and the way
if you really were to try to solve it is
the same thing um we did with
the pasas and which is that you you you
have to report in you know you file a
report to that that clearing house and
in that Clearing House you've got to
explain what's in it and so that you can
why you can claim that it's truly what
we're talking about is composting food
and I don't know how you would have I
thought you was talking about the
packaging that the well that's true it
would be the pack there was a packaging
says that it's biodegradable
package talking who the heck knows
whether it's biodegradable or
not and that's the thing that's that's
the enforceability so that was say the
Pas is a great example and remember this
started out with Mercury okay is that
these these Clearing Houses where you
document what you're doing and and then
then you're then you get your your
certification going forward that that
you you filed that so obviously um the
issue of packaging bio integr packaging
uh is not as as important as P or
Mercury Mr chair yes um my question
is in regards to this particular uh area
is is that a is is there a
national um no that's the problem so
we're doing it state by state he he yeah
absolutely
and it's it's you know States if states
are passing it it's purely feel-good I
mean one of the things of you learning
more and more is that a lot of States
they just pass stuff and and I guess the
assumption is that somebody just drops a
dime some you know and brings it to all
places the Attorney General's office and
so you had some states that the AG's
office
are evidently have lawyers with nothing
better to do and take cases up like the
we don't we don't have that resource
here in the state well no that's my my
point I would think it' be a federal man
yeah it should be
but I mean I mean right now the only
people we the FDA you know looks at
what's inside the package but I don't
believe they have any regulations on
outside the package do anybody know who
anybody here from we don't have anybody
from EG here okay
motion Herbert do you want to make the
perfect
yes okay any discussion on the motion
all those in favor raise her hand you're
you're here saie okay
yeah okay two three four five six seven8
nine right
subcommittee we had to keep just shy of
a
quorum okay uh next 721 gold is legal
tender
to so I'll move to retain
uh the bill needs a little bit of work
to make it
uh uh you know something that is an
imperative to pass uh we suffer from not
having a sales tax or an income tax
suffer and so if we did that would make
it more uh you know it make yeah more
relevant to passing but uh so really So
when you buy gold in states that have
sales tax you actually pay the sales tax
on the purchase of that gold you
do we we do have some rules on we do
have some rules on barter
believe away that how about coin if you
buy uh you know old used old coins I
believe it's just treated as a normal
sale yeah so it's it's a sales so you
still pay sales tax yeah you know it
could be 5 six 8% you got you got one of
those half pennies which I was just
reading about I stuff from Littleton
Coin and it says out of state there's a
sales tax right on the bill right
unbelievable okay so so reluctantly move
to
retain no I realized you're reluctant
yeah and we you know the issue is we got
to figure out how to how how to make
sense of it so that you know I mean
because the end of the day it's going to
the exemption list would be could be
very long and that's problematic
representative Gibbs thank you Mr chair
um ever since we had the uh public
hearing on this bill I've been thinking
of trying to walk into some place like
Target with a bag of gold coins and
reasonable Keith you want to
respond I mean there there are uh gold
back credit cards there's there's ways
to use gold to purchase things that are
modern you know like you don't have to
be a pirate with a sack of gold to go
into Target you can use a a credit card
that's back by gold I still don't think
it's
reasonable but that you know that credit
card thing that we were talking about we
investigated that credit card kind of a
scheme last year and the losses that you
take and the overhead that you pay for
makes it I if you look at it carefully
you're taking such a hit on what the
value of that gold is that I would
rather go into a deli with a lump of
gold than buy one of those credit cards
well I mean
obviously if you if you own gold bars or
you have these own you know you don't
actually have them at home right you
have it's somewhere else is stored and
but you don't know where you have it or
even if they bought gold with it you
literally don't know yeah
well don't they send you a picture of
BL doesn't have like a Serial I buy gold
all the time all I just remember is that
Indiana would had the the Nazi uh you
know signal stamped on the gold bar
that's say if they did melt it down that
that gold bar still would exist
right
what gold bar with stamps on
it what we saying did Nazi had the Nazi
Jones right exactly Mr sh one more
comment yes I think by retaining this
bill we could send a message that we
would like to know if there is gold in
Fort Knox that we're interested in that
we want to know what's it what's really
stashed away it could be on a credit
card in there huh haven't you seen gold
finger I I do one one of my favorite
Bond
movies okay
actually yeah but he throws he throws a
gold barn on the golf course right on
chairman I have a
question yes so do you have any kind of
uh legal framework that how much we can
buy the gold in a year or at a time at
this point we have no regulations on it
okay and and I'm not sure what time when
you came in the room but represent Ammon
pointed out that this this issue is
actually um more Forefront in a state
that has a sales tax okay but because we
don't have a sales
tax uh except we might charge a sales
tax on trees here in New
Hampshire so he has to say I am opposed
to House Bill 123 and I will speak to it
tomorrow um but second anyway so
representative Ammon and second by
representative
pus moves to retain any more discussion
on the
motion seeing none all those in favor
raise your hand
liquor okay all right we got nine okay
Nine's
zip okay tokens study study
here's my
all
right yeah so this is it's uh replaces
the entire bill um so I'll just go over
the the differences uh rep Spears had
some suggestions I Incorporated some of
them but not all of them
um I'll just go through it uh line 17 on
the first
page so the the the recommendations that
the commission would make I added uh
legal regulatory so letter B there legal
regulatory financial and technological
considerations for state level
regulatory
framework uh line 23 I added we're
looking at what they're doing at the
federal level because that's very
relevant right now
um we also added in blockchainbased
trust so exploring this idea of uh
creating a blockchainbased trust that
came out of 302 we decided to punt it
put it in the study
commission uh I added line 26 I added
Environmental Protection as one of the
considerations because there's there's
uh thoughts around the energy use of
blockchain um and we'll see that in uh
blockchains that can support stable
tokens they have to be smart contract
blockchains Mo most of those are using
proof of stake which uses less
none let's see and then the
members uh in talking to you yesterday
chair hunt I added uh House of
Representatives that's suppos to
say that change did not get in there
that was supposed to be line 31 was
supposed to be the Commerce Committee I
don't know why that changed make that's
fine all right it's still yeah the the
speaker makes three of members
appointment yeah I mean there could be
somebody
else in the house that's that's fine
that's broad enough okay yeah he'll he
he he'll bring it to me and ask for my
recommendations okay all right uh let's
see uh I added on page two line three
Secretary of State or design because it
could it could touch on Securities
laws uh attorney general design that
could be uh it could touch on consumer
protection as actually one of the
charges instead of one representative
line five page two I made it two
representatives from the blockchain
industry I I thought they there' be
enough to fill those
the the repeal date on line 27 we pushed
it out a year it was November 1st 2025
so now it's 2026 and then on line 20 I
changed the report date to to match the
repal
date I think that's you know it's
basically the same bill just a little
little more detail yeah good some bones
I like I like having lots of charges
because one of my my complaints a lot of
commissions they have like one sentence
since
like useless I mean these are three big
topics to get through in one year it's
going interes this will keep them busy
yeah okay Mr chair yes just to get it
into the record the uh I'm I'm a little
not confused but I'm I'm a little uh I
find it interesting that all the states
are a number of the states are doing
basically the same effort that
representative Ammon is interested in
right
and and now uh if I understand things
Trump president Trump has an interest
specifically in he's got one right in
these in this this this concept I'm just
wondering
is to me it seems as though this is
going to be a mess if it's not organized
and it sounds to me like even though Mr
Ammon might have it all figured out
there's other states may not do the same
thing and and I I find it worrisome that
it would go into let with the one state
would uh be
um putting it out and and adopting it
for uh uh you know
National use I would I would prefer a
federal uh effort standard yes yeah and
so I just want to get it into the record
because this is very very complicated it
there have some problems and uh it's
going to be a mess if if we get inv I
look at the first charge which says the
current
landscape okay landscape would include
States and federal this is on line 18
onea first directive what's going on out
there and to me that that's both state
and Federal yeah line 23 as
well okay and and uh so I I feel and
actually then Federalist specifically
say stated in 23 so so there it's all
there it's just that um what we're
trying to do is create a One-Stop
shopping where in state here in New
Hampshire we have a group of people who
are going to be experts on this subject
so if and when something does come
forward we we have group of people can
come in and help explain it to us okay
yeah just for the record I would like to
be assured that we're not the only uh
dog in this fight and uh uh and we have
there will be different opinions even on
the on the pro side but I mean I'm
totally con I'm I'm sure that that and
that's one of the reasons why you create
a committee like this is so they can
thrash that
out and just for the record okay there
is a pending Federal legislation that
that may get passed while this
commission is is meeting right and then
the question will be what room does this
do the states have to innovate yeah
where where are we after that right but
and and how much are they taking on
versus how much they're delegating would
could be delegating to the states
anyways absolutely and taking in
consideration that you know the way New
Hampshire runs his laws like the fact
that we don't have a sales tax might
have an impact
so okay is the question clear the yes
thank you thank you chair my question to
uh I mean is U so right now we are just
creating the committee we are deciding
the committee who will be the
participant and all and then you will be
that committee is going to basically
forms a guideline and that will well
they no they will give us a report and
suggested legislation and then we have a
chance to review that right exactly okay
all right thank you yeah this is this
is okay so representative em and second
represent I just want to get moves ought
to pass on the amendment
number
943 yes represent spe how long did the
last commission take about was it a year
or a year and a half yeah it lasted a
year but okay so if we allocating a year
we're okay I think so I mean it's going
to be a heavy lift but yeah speaker
doesn't like study committees anyway
so we don't want to go too far out so I
I looked that uh we we're look I looked
to see if we could repeal some of the
obsolete study commissions and I didn't
see any that uh cross with commerce's
business oh good that's you did ask me
about that yeah I said to him if there's
any because we've been we have been
pretty good about not passing study
committees
all right the question is on the
amendment all those in favor please
hand yeah and all those
to1 I don't I don't like this
configuration I like the old committee
when I can see I can see yeah I can see
everybody
better this is all right
okay so now the motion is out to pass as
amended all those in favor say
one
retain representative
Cole um again this is we just want us to
say that we we are aware that there's
potential problems going on out there
we're sensitive to it and we want
everyone to know that uh if if something
really did come up that was clearly
needs to be addressed then we do have a
vehicle to address it with but otherwise
otherwise we're just retaining it to
send a message that we we know this is a
problem but at this point we we have we
don't have the exact language of how we
want to zero in on the problem yes one
of the problems that we had is when this
bill came up is that just about every
organization that's out there banking
everybody yeah were against it and so
even is that a problem or is that
expected but so if if in fact the uh we
were to drag it out you know because
something happened in the future it's
couldn't be that same bill because there
was so many organizations against it I
would say if there were to address it it
would be we wouldn't want to narrow it
to the problem we that that we got okay
because it was very wi it was a you know
a wi sweep of everything so we want to
be if if we're going to solve a problem
we want to we want to know exactly which
problem we're solving and that we're
going to pass something that's
enforcable uh to address the problem so
we would be prepared to modify the devil
out of it absolutely it will it will be
put on a huge
diet I would prefer to
this just get rid of it no because we we
want people to know that we that we're
paying attention to this problem I have
learned from personal experience retain
is
better
yes I'm still paying there's one bill
one bill that you wouldn't listen to me
when I said let's retain it and you guys
but if you had said something I did I
told you you that your Democrats would
be all over you like a wet rag no you
later but anyway retain is better I well
always say that my notes said retain on
my notes I always had retain and it's
you guys inist I was too wound up and
Medicare representative Ammon thank you
I I just wanted to say say the sponsors
of this bill are not imagining a problem
that doesn't exist this is actually a
problem um I don't know if the state
level is the appropriate level of
government to deal with it but it's
being handled at the federal level
there's pressure being put on Banks and
I have in front of me this is a headline
from two days ago Fox Business JP Morgan
Chase makes moves to prevent religious
political de banking so the the the
banks even the big banks are getting
pressure to address this issue you were
I mean even the the president's wife
Melania Trump was debanked that's what
we take well that's just one example
it's just one I mean it's a fact you
don't have to react emotionally to it
you know yeah but anyway so I think
prain is a good way to approach this
because it's it keeps the conversation
going and our state is looking at the
issue I mean you know where I stand on
this I had a version of last year but I
do think I'm still confused why the
government needs to I'm not saying hey
I'm not going to fight it like the last
one but but um when we say that there's
a problem it feels like somebody didn't
get something they wanted versus some
objective objective flaw in the system
that needs to be fixed and I don't think
I don't think many of the people on this
committee or the people in the in the
audience were particularly convinced
that there is a problem as much as they
don't like outcomes and they want to
ensure that those outcomes don't occur I
think I think the the market does a
pretty good job of dealing with these
sorts of problems if some bank is going
to discriminated against you because of
your political beliefs or whatever you
own guns or you want to don't want to
invest in an oil company then that is
that bank's prerogative and I think
another bank can fill in to fill that
void and I think that most of these
problems to the extent that there's ex
to the extent that there is some sort of
real discrimination going against things
that people cannot control obviously
that should be addressed but I don't
know that this bill is even attempting
to solve those sorts of problems I think
by and large those problems are taken
care of by current laws that's my
understanding anyways yeah but I I would
have to say that if it become to my
attention that something came up in the
state of New
Hampshire then absolutely I would rely
on Kei and you to help me research it
and see whether there's any truth behind
it can I just respond um so this isn't a
problem of the free market it's a
problem of Regulation that's unclear
that the banks need to respond to and
they they're taking a very cautious
approach like any question about a
particular individual uh what's been
happening is they get debanked they have
to get a new bank account um and and
they they lose access to their funds for
a period of time and it's well
documented there's it's called operation
chokepoint and operation chokepoint 2.0
you can you can look that up I mean
those were real efforts by the federal
government to crowd out or to uh
restrict access to the financial system
of particular Industries including the
the marijuana industry so I mean it's
not a partisan thing this is you said
you mentioned guns uh Cannabis shops and
and others right that uh got swept up
into this so it's a real thing but I
don't think the state we don't have the
authority to to address it
representative Gibs
thank you Mr chair um I would support
what representative Sullivan said um and
also I should point out that
discrimination based on factors that
cannot be controlled are pretty well
taken care of by the federal Equal
Credit Opportunity Act so I don't think
we have to be concerned about those um
but this bill is a generalized attempt
to prevent the banks from uh and
insurance companies too it has Insurance
in it
also it has Insurance in it also prevent
Banks and insurance companies from
considering um elements that are
elements of the record of the applicant
for a loan for instance uh that cannot
be Quantified but are nevertheless
relevant to uh the issue of whether uh a
business is going to succeed or fail and
is therefore likely qualified for a loan
so um I think that is something that we
can leave to the market and as
representative Sullivan said One Bank
might um consider such a factor and
reject an applicant because of that but
another bank might accept the the
applicant I think that is something we
could leave to the market and I would
prefer to see this um uh voted itl as
you I agree well right right now we're
we're in subcommittee so obviously would
you're preparing for when we exec this
bill next week um yes um I'm just giving
you my opinion I I'm not on the
subcommittee so it's not up to me I know
that okay I I would just like to Second
the the the idea that we don't want to
tread on the free market and this bill
could potentially do that by causing
more uncertainty causing a bigger
problem than it intends to fix so right
I I'm in agreement with there so see we
we find some things we can agree on and
then that's what we'll work from going
forward every so often we do yes but it
does mean we'll talk about it again in
September and and uh see see where where
we can find we can agree on but right
now we're kind out of out of time okay
so
um I I I think I made the motion to
retain you change it from Co to you and
and Cole was my second was or did Cole
did make oh yeah that's right that we
had that's correct okay any uh any more
discussion on retaining 359 seeing none
all those sub committee
agree four five six seven eight n nine
zip
perfect okay nine
I I got it right
here
two three
and okay good morning good morning
morning Mr chairman and members of the
of the subcommittee um Tom Conley from
the Secretary of State's office uh what
you have before you is an amendment to
House Bill 406 uh this amendment
replaces the bill in its entirety um
it's a I'm sorry you still passing that
out
okay okay now what you all have before
you is an amendment to House Bill 406 uh
the amendment replaces the bill in its
entirety uh the amendment uh was drafted
uh with the consultation of the business
industry Association to address concerns
that they had with the initial bill uh
the amendment Narrows the scope of the
bill and I'll just give you a quick
summary of what it now includes um we've
basically taken out um the the
provisions that were proposed in the St
that would allow us to um uh to validate
data that was submitted in a filing
prior to its approval what we've done
now is narrowed the scope of our
Authority to review after either we
receive a written complaint from a
consumer or from a business that their
identity has been stolen or information
has been used uh to uh create an entity
that they're unaware of that they have
the capacity to file a for a sworn
statement with us and that would allow
us to then um uh remove that that
fraudulent or authorized filing from the
record um so we've got remaining in the
remaining bill here first is to it does
create minimum requirements for persons
who are acting as a registered agent if
they're an individual they'll need to be
18 years of age and be a resident of the
State of New Hampshire and have a
physical address in the
state um the bill also closes a known
loophole we have in the current law
where people um will use a commercial
post office provider like the UPS store
for example as the registered agent
address and obviously that person is not
physically there there's only a a post
office box there right so what we've
done here is specified that you can use
that commercial address or that Virtual
Office address for your business or
mailing address but for a registered
agent address again that person has to
be physically located at that location
to use that address as their registered
office um it also provides a means for
redress for persons or businesses who've
had their address or business details
used without their permission allows us
to remove or cancel filings found to be
authorized or fraudulent and it does
provide for a penalty current law um in
the business Corporation act indicates
it's a misdemeanor um to file a
fraudulent filing and it creates that
penalty for persons who provide false
information or make it unauthorized
filing with the secretary of state so
that's basically the the intent the
intent and the scope of the bill um as I
said the the um the amendment Narrows
what we originally were proposing and we
believe some of the concerns we
discussed in our in our pre at the
hearing about uh providing security for
folks who are filing and creating
businesses online that um we're
continuing to to do that using utilizing
technology and we're as I mentioned
we're preparing to issue an RFP to
replace the current um quick start
filing system um and some of those are
enhancements we anticipate we'll be
we'll be part of that uh so happy to
answer any questions that you would have
amendment okay uh representative amens
first thank you for your testimony um
just looking at line 16 on the first
page it
says no no business entity required to
maintain a registered office in the
state shall designate the address of a
commercial post office so which
businesses are required to maintain a
registered office and I'm thinking that
there's you know there's a lot of work
from home businesses that don't have a
you know a central office that the it's
sort of like a virtual staff um which
business are required to maintain an
office that they couldn't use a
thirdparty post office box um all
business entities in New Hampshire are
required to have a registered office
with the exception of domestic
nonprofits um and the folks who register
as a trade name that don't form a
business but just Reg or DBA they're not
required to have a a registered office
address so um limited Partnerships
limited liability Partnerships
corporations llc's and now also Dows
would also be another entity that would
be required to have a um a registered
agent um under this under the statute so
registered agent versus registered
office so a doubt would be okay I don't
know the difference so I'm just yeah the
registered agent being that individual
in the registered office being the
address of that individual okay um a
person that that's that's creating a
business and it's homebased if they want
to serice with their own agent they can
list their resident address as their
registered officer they're allowed to do
that it just in a situation where they
may not want to have their reg the
resident address on the public record
that they may choose to use their
attorney a CPA or or a third party to
act as their agent in those
cases question representative Herbert um
I'm interested in in um understanding
why this
legislation came up at this point in
time sure um actually the the this is an
issue that um many states are battling
with right now people either forming
what we calling synthetic entities
businesses that have been created
utilizing the the data from existing
businesses to make it appear that they
already are in business um or situations
where people's address is being used
we're finding more and more times that
people are creating an business entity
and using somebody else's address as
their as their physical address um uh
and as a result of that we see we had a
couple of situations a couple of
businesses one in in do one in Portsmith
um Happ to be restaurants that were um
where people where were someone um
filing online were able to create
business entities with very similar
names using their address and and uh and
other details so they actually when they
received in the mail a a bank statement
from Chase Bank that someone had opened
up a bank account um utilizing that that
name and address and and that they were
trying to obviously trally either
attempt to obtain credit or other
fraudulent activities using that that
business detail we had to in order to
work with those businesses to get these
these these fraudulent businesses off
the Record we really didn't have a means
to do that so that was why we originally
brought the bill to the to the committee
this year just so I understand uh the
example you gave was the synthetic
somebody was a fraud correct but but
they were trying to establish a a line
of credit somewhere
and I is this like the drug business
that uh is dominant there or is um what
I've learned from talking to folks like
den and Brad street and other folks who
are who have expertise in this area um
it's present for any number reasons it
could be something as simple as someone
again wanting to create a bank account
go and say open a bank account and put
$100 in it and then let this LLC sit up
there for a couple of years so that it
begins to develop a history so that they
looks like it's a legitimate business or
um maybe something as simple as going
online and changing the name of the
person who's the member or manager of
that business well that's the one I was
most worried okay was that when I log in
because you know I have to every year
now and I and I'm treasur of a
historical society and and you know so
I'm two Treasure of two different
entities let alone I have a couple of
names I reserve let alone my business
and what scared me was that that anybody
could get access into my account and
change the addresses and change that
who's who's the
members and then go to the bank and
claim that that you know because the
bank says show us you know let's pull up
your your your state web page and they
go online and they'll get it they'll get
that information and they're getting
fraudulent information correct because
you allow them these people to get into
my account I hope you really you guys
are fixing this problem well I said I
assure you that we're not letting them
get into your account and I don't mean
to been semantics here but the account
you you create to to do business with
with the secetary state is is separate
and unque from your bus the actual
entity that I am updating you know pay
my 50 $75 whatever the right yeah what
we have in place right now outrageous
amounts of money we allowed you to
charge
us um we said but right now um if
anybody files a document with your on
someone the business entity yeah we have
a t flag so that you receive a call
know what we anticipate with our next
system is we'll have an authentic
company authorization code where
someone's going to have to have that
code in order to be able to go ahead and
file that and that fortunately won't
require legislative action for us to be
able to put that in place representative
Gibbs thank you
um do I understand correctly that the
main difference between this and the
original bill is that the secretary of
state would investigate on the basis of
a complaint rather than verifying every
time correct um where did I I'm sorry I
just scan it quickly but where does it
say that the secretary would investigate
I see it says the secretary of state
will take the following actions and then
there is the opportunity for complaints
but I don't see where it says the
secretary would investigate on the basis
of the complaint um what would I
anticipate happening we say if the
information they're provided with their
sworn statement you know or ability for
us to validate those facts that we can
take action without taking any further
action but typically a sworn statement
would require a police report will allow
we obviously will'll rely on the the um
actions of the of the police department
to take any further action but the fact
that they've they've reported it as a
crime and then provided us with a
statement indicating so would be enough
for us to take the action so we don't
anticipate doing any um say um deep
investigations by any threat we don't
have investigative staff or
investigative Authority so it would
really be our actions would be based on
that in the worst case scenario would be
is we remove a document based on that
sword statement and then someone comes
back and says that person lied right and
we can put the that put that document
back on the record um and they can
always um obviously can always U um
uh petition to to have us review any any
rejection of a document that we that we
already haven't filed the provision and
already in the law to do that right this
is this is
a130 powers and then the next year was
a139 so there's there's 30 I'm sure 31
or 32 talks about how you begin yes
that's in the existing so that's already
ination law law yes sir you follow
that okay yes R Sal thank you thank you
chair for taking my question uh right
now what I understood is if we need to
have a registered agent physically in
the state and the office can be a PO Box
is that correct um no this say if they
are currently now is that that there has
to be a physical street address but what
folks are doing is they providing the
street address of that local um business
that provides the PO boxes so they're
they're for example if they're using
Staples as their as their Virtual Office
they're providing 76 Ford Eddie Plaza as
the street address for the registered
office and we're indicating that if we
know that they're not physically there
they don't go to that office on a
regular basis they're they're not
physically there that that address would
not be be used to be able to use to be
the registered office so my followup
question is how we are going to do the
compliance on this do you have any kind
of edits in the system or you're going
to do it manually that somebody's not
following this guideline um we obviously
we do know who the known commercial Pro
box office providers are in the state
already I mean as far as where the local
UPS Stores or the Val office so we have
that information we can put that into
our system so that if those dresses come
up that we will flag them for us for
review okay thank you I have followes
thank you just so I get it uh
what what division what department are
you in the corporation division of the
secretary of state Secretary of State
yeah now and the Attorney General's
office uh is separate uh from your your
uh business or your authority authority
so I'm my question is at what point does
it go uh become a legal matter that I
think like the Attorney General would be
uh interested in Prosecuting I mean is
it your your responsibility to prosecute
these things it's not currently we we
can make referrals either to the to the
uh the county attorney or to the reg
attorney general um if with a violation
of the statute but it's up to them then
I'll be determined whether it's
something they want to further
investigate or or pursue but you would
make a recommendation yes sir yes so uh
thanks to frm Scandal um the the
Departments the AG's banking insurance
and securities meets once a month I
think it's once a month and you get and
they exchange any sketchy things that
are going on so that that they're
communicating there's communic so that
Scandal
okay second by representative
hunt
okay any discussion on the motion of
960 no no yeah yeah they've been House
number we're moving at the speed of
light
here
yeah yes
Mark oh excuse
me that was a Fran slip I just said that
there I don't know if you saw he me when
I said sorry my my brain was a little
delayed there on this question um how
since you you said you know all the post
office providers the private post office
box providers do you have an idea of how
much this bill would impact existing
businesses um you know have you done any
queries on to see you know how many
businesses are would not be in
compliance that are currently um
actually but not that any queries on
that um I don't anticipate it it would
be a large one we often catch these at
the time of the um right now where we
would we would bounce them back
typically indicate and to verify is that
person at that physical address and they
would normally go ahead and make that
correction before and then be submitted
for filing so I think that the the
number of file business that would be
impacted by it would be um there would
not be a dramatically would not be a
large number but perhaps be piing you
know making a educated guest it would be
certainly okay do you get get the r heat
or no we don't have one he's going to
get one but I can write everything down
okay all right so uh representative
melier moves uh second from represent
hunt moves out to pass on
H any discussion on the
question seeing none all those in favor
raise their
hand are you R
okay two that's all right
three about about nine because Cole's
not here so eight8 all those opposed
okay eight to
myself okay the motion is ought to pass
as amended any discussion on that
hand four eight seven eight
okay I know I'm I'm a bad counter
because when we did it the exact session
okay yeah
okay all right next up 427 amending the
UCC is that you JD is that your bill
back
up I was just having a conversation with
another chairman and I said um when
you're executing a bill or you're doing
a bill you actually want to know
everybody in the audience and know why
they're there because it might give you
a hint and who really cares about that
bill and I see you hovering back there
so I know this must be yours so my
memory was this was a uh you're
remending the UCC over this theory about
soundness of money of the of and and um
our UCC guy is telling us that this is
not something that's coming from
Chicago and we normally when it comes to
the rsas and what's over there
everything is is comes from Chicago
because the whole point of the UCC is to
is to be
uniform so we we sort of have a problem
with your bill because it we he we
haven't got the Chicago blessing on it
and and uh uh let alone that we did have
a lot of give or take there to try to
understand what you were trying to do so
um what what should we do with this bill
we can't really pass it we we can retain
it you know if you want to keep this
conversation going is there any hope
that this that Chicago is ever going to
buy into what you're working on in terms
of this
bill well I I I don't know whether
Chicago is going to take this up unless
the stat say that it needs to be taken
up I mean essentially just for the
committee what what what happened
starting in the 90s and as the uh UCC
was amended sections eight and sections
n uh and uh our representative Mr Mooney
was the Godfather of this entire uh op
operation here change of the law
basically taking
ownership physical ownership of your
property and turning it into a security
entitlement which effectively had all
the same uh indicaa of ownership except
if the
intermediaries one of the intermediaries
in the process goes insolvent if they go
insolvent then all of a sudden you do
not have ownership anymore your your
security is is in is in a giant pile of
Securities held by the various
intermediaries and the and the that the
top of the of the chain the banks take
that
asset you can look at the Layman uh
Brothers uh case that happened uh and
you have uh members that had assets
there they're they're still fighting to
to get them back and that's the problem
this this is not a problem until you
have an insolvency when you do you are
out your property that is fundamentally
wrong that's a fraud on New
Hampshire uh owners of stocks and bonds
it's a fraud on New Hampshire pensioners
who who rely on pension systems it' be a
fraud on the New Hampshire treasury in
my
opinion and so this issue has been
recognized by people in the states it
was it went under the radar for years
and years and years it's now been
recognized and multiple states have
taken up the issue of this needs to get
fixed and the way to fix it is to repeal
these sections that maybe will force the
uh the uh
uh ulc to uh uh you know take the issue
up and fix it but this issue needs to be
fixed what states have passed this
there's no states that have passed it
yet it's in progress in in several
States okay so retaining it would be
okay retaining it would be find out
other stat keep it alive yes um but uh I
I would commend New Hampshire to be
first in the nation to take care of its
citizens uh being the first in nation
and amending the UCC is probably not
something I'm too excited about but
representative spear has a question
before we uh take a vote on this uh Mr
Moody gave us a uh paper that had talks
about some of these issues and I think
I'd like to hear what he has to say yes
that I I certainly was going to invite
him up represent Amon I just I have a
a logistics or a technical question yeah
is it possible to amend a bill to to
turn it into a resolution or is that is
that not allowed not allowed okay we
tried that in Science and Tech didn't
work didn't work out that that answers
my question well needs to say I I've
I
wouldn't
okay uh because I don't think
resolutions are worth the paper they're
printed on I mean who's who who actually
pays any attention to a resolution well
so my thinking is uh Mr Mooney is our
state representative one of two
positions to the ulc and if maybe we had
some language to sort of direct him in a
certain direction that got passed by the
house memory his testimony was that he
he he wasn't buying into the whole thing
so well it it's the will of the house
that we're talking about right
right okay anybody any other questions
for JD I I would just say that if you're
going to have Mr Mooney go to Chicago
you're having the fox guard the hen
house I I that's that's a major problem
since he created it well he and all the
other people in the US I understand but
he was the
drafter
okay so you're telling us we shouldn't
bother listening to him no I'm saying
you need
understand that that's he's
the problem got it okay but then there's
also the other side dare I say that this
bill was brought together by somebody
who's making money on a book so we we
can't the calling the kettle black he's
not making any money on the book he his
book is online for
okay any R there we we what is good
about this we get two sides which I
always like when I hear two sides that
that makes it easier for me so thank you
all
right chairman Vice chairman members of
the
committee I guess I
have something to agree with the
previous speaker there indeed is a an
ongoing fraud on New Hampshire and you
just heard
it I don't say that lightly but let me
just
say this claim that the
1994 amendments to article
every complaint that's made about those
amendments existed before those
amendments in
Spades the idea of this security
entitlement somehow watering
down the rights that existed before
wrong the security entitlement
represents the property right and all
the rights that
an investor would have against its
intermediary the broker or the bank or
whoever under the law or under the
contract it's the entire package it was
just a drafting
mechanism those property rights are
actually enhanced under that law not
diminished at
all the investor under that
law has a right if they act without
knowledge
of some adverse
claim to immunity from anybody suing
them over their rights in the underlying
Securities that they get by virtue of
the credit to their account and you know
I won't try to present all the evidence
today because there's several points to
make but I think it would be a huge
mistake to uh retain this bill there's
nothing uh four states have considered
it so far this year for a vote North and
South Dakota Tennessee and Y moming all
of them voted
down uh the bill in Mississippi died
without even a hearing and we're told
with some assurance that in Oklahoma
it's not even going to get a
hearing uh in four other States
including New Hampshire there has been
but no vote so I would hope that New
Hampshire would not be the first state
that would buy into Mr web's fantasy
great taking conspiracy theory that
really has no basis in
fact turning to what we just
heard the idea that the person that has
a Securities account and gets a credit
gives up his
property is just not
right the only way that property would
go away in an
there's a
default
on a
loan that
the
investor has taken out otherwise it
retains all of its
claims to the extent investors have
consented as they do in any margin
account they agree that the intermediary
can for example pledge their
Securities I me can anybody believe when
you consent to your securities being
pledged that you're saying oh but of
course my rights are superior to the
lender not
likely inconceivable in
fact now the lender to the intermediary
which is the priority here can only
obtain the value of the Securities to
secure the
debt and the debt of the inter mediary
cannot
exceed all of the debts of its customers
so when you wash it out all they can do
is satisfy that debt but the excess
value over the secuity pledge to secure
that debt would of course come back the
only way that could Advantage is if both
the intermediaries and solvent and the
lender insolvent so the lender can't
even give back the excess collateral
cushion
and for
this fantasy Theory to take place it
would take hundreds or thousands of
intermediaries to be insolvent and their
lendage to be insolvent it just can't
happen the arithmetic doesn't work so
this theory is not there the idea that
this was something that was
created uh in 1994 is just
absurd yes my scholarship was
responsible for the core of those
changes although there were a lot of
changes made of course in the drafting
committee I was an American Bar
Association
advisor but I had to fight a lot of the
financial industry to come up with this
idea because when you have intermediated
bul normal property rules don't apply
very well the first in time first in
right so we came up with a system where
the rights of
the investor are going to be greater
protected with this protection from
being sued all they had to give up with
the idea that
somehow if they somehow could trace
their Securities which are settled in
fungible bulks and netted out which is
very
unlikely that somehow if in the
insolvency the trustee didn't go after
customer assets which they virtually
always
would that the customer would not be
able to sue in most
circumstances but the point is that just
means the customer can't sue the
customer of another firm the customer
only has rights against the firm that it
selected and nobody can take those
assets away from it because it has uh
immunity uh finally
uh this could have an adverse impact in
particular on intermediaries and their
credit opportunities other than broker
dealers for the broker dealers where
most people have their Securities
accounts secured creditors of the broker
dealers have had
priority in Liquidation in in insolvency
for many years it's been cified in the
bankruptcy code and in the Securities
investor protection act beginning in
1938 there's no change here this is a
this is a solution in search of a
problem that just does not exist and the
idea that all of the organizations that
represent consumers that represent
investors that were involved in this
process have been sitting there being
unaware of this they've got a a video
out that says somehow this was secret
there's nothing secret about it I CED in
the paper I distributed the website of
of where you can look up and find out
about customer protections and what
happens
just I'm sorry to have to be so emphatic
but I've never in any sort of
forum uh had to confront a situation
where people would just stand up and
flat out say things that are inaccurate
to try to persuade a legislative body so
happy to take any
questions welcome to the legislative
process well I've been R it a little bit
represent Hammond thank you Mr Moody for
your testimony um during the public
hearing you know I heard both sides and
that's what we do here it's a you know
there's some debate that happens um it
seemed that one side was talking about
the normal course of business and the
other side was talking about a
catastroph a catastrophic situation
where you know it's a it's a 2008
collapse um if you focus on that extreme
scenario you know they've they happen
periodically every couple of decades
um is there any truth in the in the
scenario where lots of firms become ins
solvent that investors are sort of cut
off from tracing their ownership to a
particular security because they're held
in this the fungible bulk that that's my
question sure I don't think there is any
truth in it we've had those
catastrophes in the past and the system
has worked very well it certainly worked
very well in 2008 if you just
do the
arithmetic on the Securities that are
pledged you don't lose ownership of
something I mean it only secures a debt
the property transfer is to the extent
of the value of the borrowings so that's
all that would be at risk and of course
that would be offset that's already been
transferred and uh broker dealers can
only use that of course for uh customer
purposes uh so this would definitely be
a
problem one of the main
reasons that the 1994 amendments came
about triggered in first by some
government securities dealers failures
those dealers were not regulated broker
dealers and then concern about
crisis the entire Financial economy of
this country depends on
collateral virtually all of the
investment markets whether it's real
estate Finance depends on collateral and
the problem was that due to some
arguments made there was concern with
these unregulated intermediaries that
the collateral wouldn't stand
up and that's what this was about I
didn't think the amendments were talking
about 8511 were necessary because things
were working just fine but some members
of the drafting committee wanted to set
a new rule that says customers come
first but of course to pledge their
Securities the customer has to
consent and then we had to offset that
with the private ority rule that would
not be inconsistent with what we saw
with the broker dealers and which has
always been the rule for secured credit
and
insolvency so I don't think there is any
any basis for that when you uh when you
numbers okay R up okay represent spear
uh Leman Brothers was brought up could
you explain what went on there or what
to well since it had nothing to do with
these priority
rules which weren't applied and which
were not involved in the case that they
keep raising I can't explain it that's
why I've pointed out that it's
false I mean I can't explain and you
know I'm not I'm just an itinerate
retired law professor I can't explain
why someone wants to make false claims
but you know I'm maybe I'm learning
something about
that too but in that case involves some
Safe Harbor rules under the bankruptcy
code which
protect transferees and certain
Securities transactions from having
their transactions avoided in a
bankruptcy and that was involved in a
chapter 11 bankruptcy of the parent not
the broker
dealer uh uh so those rules didn't apply
I've written highly critically of those
rules that we need the Safe Harbor rules
but not as broad as they are and I've
criticized them for being as broad as
they are but that's beside the point
these priority rules weren't weren't
case okay I have a question
representative Herbert this is uh super
complicated yes and and uh I I was a
broker when uh uh two of the biggest
crashes happened I had nothing to do
with it but the fact of the matter is
the fact of the matter is do you people
went bankrupt the dealers uh Leman is
the last example I guess but there was a
savings and loan crisis before that
where a bunch of broker dealers went uh
bankrupt I I would like to have my
question is is if this is not germine in
other words it's been the way this is
how it works and I understand that and
if somebody is trying to change it I I'm
having difficulty understanding uh how I
mean if you went and and and bought a
lot of Securities through a a legitimate
broker dealer and then a catastrophe
happens which is happens more often than
you would imagine uh that you can
somehow go back and uh grab you grab the
uh
assets you know your money you can't I
mean it's it's gone the collateral was
levered to the point where it didn't it
didn't have they didn't have enough
money
to uh you know send the money back to
the whoever had bought the Securities so
I mean I don't understand what we're
trying to change here because okay
that's your question that the my you
know that's a that's a statement that's
so would you believe yeah okay worked
very well that under the Securities
investor protection act losses of
customers uh over the covered amount
have been you know teeny
teeny tiny and those losses are
protected for individual
investors per per each account up to
500,000 in losses so if we imagined a
loss A shortfall in customer Securities
of unheard of proportions say
10% for you not to be covered you would
have to have 5 million in your account
but if the losses are more
likely in the 1% or less range of a of a
shortfall in those few cases where there
have been shortfalls it would be many
many times that that you would have to
lose to to uh in your accounts to to uh
not be be covered of your loss so it's
it's worked very well this is something
that's come up in crypto and I site the
chief Council of coinbase one of the
largest exchanges which also acts as
custodian he tweeted not long ago that
article 8 is the pillar of commercial
law because it protects the customers
and they get it rather than the
creditors on the other hand coinbase
does have for certain kinds of
investors some margin Arrangements which
would allow them to reh hypothecate if
they needed to fund the margin loans
those uh that's not governed by CPA just
like Banks aren't governed by CPA and
these amendments would affect that the
pending genius act in the Senate on
on uh stable coins uh provides in there
that in a custody arrangement
the custodian can reh
hypothecate Assets in order to have the
flexibility to maintain the one to one
dollar per
unit ratio so in in the world of
custodians that are not broker
dealers uh these amendments would
definitely uh chill uh or eliminate the
uh credit to the uh intermediary because
they would the only time this matters is
in
insolvency uh and if in
insolvency uh you're you're not
Keith I
mean I like the idea of retaining the
bill because uh you know obviously other
states are looking at this but I I don't
see passing it at this point so my
okay represent Amon moose retain second
by representative hunt any discussion on
[Laughter]
retain we have we have so many bills
that we're just hanging out there yeah
it's fine
uh I know they value of retaining though
I think we've we've kind of learned that
lesson that retaining is yeah I have
thank
you represent
W uh most of this is way above my head
but what what would the ramifications be
of OTP in it if it's if
it's no we don't do that but it's saying
it's that it's a very rare occasion so
because it undermines the the whole UCC
structure way the UC
law and the fundamental element of UCC
is
universality because this
that that all the states are playing by
book okay so the motion is to retain um
all those in favor raise their hand one
two three four five six seven eight nine
we just want to have you come back you
know attorney con we just we we we look
forward to seeing
September
okay getting near the end here all right
437 undis charge
mortgages um we're we have a an
amendment and and I've been just told
that the correction has been made in
this
amendment okay go that
way
and was it it was line 21 where the word
action was put
in
yeah
okay right okay yeah PA it in same thing
pair one and two and it just and this
wasn't extension yeah okay
uh so this is uh this is
um pro pro uh Expediting and having uh
title searches done quickly and easier
and with that with that with less stress
and so this is a
pro pro banking progress bill I guess
you can call it
so any any discussion um so I I move to
pass on the amendment
second by representative
pusc so we actually did have the
it and yeah you dated February 20th so
you can see the hell expeditious we were
on that kind of taken care of okay any
discussion on the motion of about to
pass on the amendment all those in in
favor yes I did I moved it and you
second it
okay all those in favor raise your hand
one two three four five six seven eight
nine zip okay uh does anybody want to
run with this bill want to be on do you
want to be on the right of blur
represent
pres you okay representative press
second by representative hunt M ought to
pass on
519 any discussion on the motion about
to pass as
amended see none all those in favor
raise your hand one two three four five
six seven eight
nine
leave now we have an amendment for it
weag yeah we we fix
things it's coming
around uh well obviously the sponsor was
in favor of the
bill okay so in the public testimony
what we heard was unbelievable high
dollar amounts being spent on Implement
on the marketing
of the
plan
so oh so I have a I have
advised uh fiscal note here too if
anybody would like to see I'll just pass
it around because we've already killed
but this was as the bill as
introduced um a question yes my
understanding is that all the marketing
was done by the provider Metropolitan
that's uh what we're expecting to happen
going forward right all
right by the insurance company yeah have
they agreed to that uh have we have they
agreed to do the marketing they'll take
over the marketing but they've been
doing it already no no we have I heard I
I yeah where are we did they agree to it
I'm I'm waiting for having someone come
commissioners of
one oh three Commissioners three Three
three it's brought out the Heavy Hitters
sorry to make you guys wait all the way
to the end end here but I'm sure you
it's been a few years since I covered
the UCC in law school so this was a
right it was kind of fun to relive UCC
it was as riveting today as it was back
then so just as a reminder um DJ beton
Court insurance department Rich labers
Deputy Commissioner over at Employment
Security Cassie Keane Deputy
Commissioner over at Das so it is
certainly I think going to be the
intention for us to have a conversation
with MetLife to take on some of the
marketing um the current marketing is
being conducted via a separate contract
with a marketing firm if I understand
the amendment correctly that would go
away yeah you you did get a copy of the
amendment right you guys okay so that
piece of it would fall away and so you'd
be left with the program so how much
money did we just save the state here
how much was that contract for I want to
know what Kudos I need to get
when I I think in our in our um budget
request pending now before division one
we had reduced uh the marketing to
200,000 so I but our contract was for
more than that um and contracts are
subject to funding appropriated by the
legislature so that's why there's a
disconnect between the two okay but so
in terms of taking these out how how
much money we're saving just 200 per
fiscal year oh per fiscal year so it's
really 400 yes what was the what was the
previous spend and what was the previous
expenditure um I thought it was like a
Million number we have spent over a
million dollars to implement um we began
implementing in 2223 so give me a moment
chair this is a combin well she's
thinking I I have a a combined down was
1.7 1.7 I have a rolled up number I'm
sorry to say it includes a consultant
1.3 in 24
we in one we spent 1.3 in fiscal year 23
combined between the marketing and the
consultant and I mentioned to you before
that we have a tiny um contract with a
company to provide the website that we
have okay so it's a rolled up number I'm
sorry this is why I'm not on finance
because numbers numbers are very fun I
can explain fible fible but let me help
explain well because somehow you somehow
in the hearing we had
1.7 I think that's a 24 number um okay
see well that was
was pass last year okay I'm sorry so it
was um I think sounds weird to you to
only 200 so two things are going on
we've already implemented so we've
stepped down our spending the other
thing is that we're before division one
in a time of of fiscal restraint right
correct so we're cutting our budget in
response to the governor's directions
and now we're working with division one
okay keep going with
it representative BRS thanks thanks and
for taking my question and recognizing
that there's zero chance of the the
budget getting bigger in terms of the
marketing how is that going to impact
the program I mean just is that
problematic
or well I think the thing about Paid
Family Medical Leave is that um getting
the word out to people that the product
exists is the most important thing right
so that's what we focused our efforts on
is getting to large employers getting to
small employers getting to individuals
so if marketing is repealed and it's a
responsibility today in the law for the
Department of administrative services
and Rich's Department Employment
Security we will no longer be doing
marketing yeah as commissioner beton
Court said it's now met life's turn to
pick up the ball sounds good and the one
good thing about this kind of a product
is it's not like people come and go um
you know once you've bought into it once
you're starting to pay into it you're
not going to you're not going to back
out so we we have that critical mass now
not only with the state employees but
with private companies um and so so and
Mr chairman I might just add I
appreciate the fact that there's some
anxiety around what
impact removing the advertising might
have to the program I think two things I
think as Cassie just me mentioned I
think metti should take on some of those
responsibilities someone who gets to see
exactly how much these companies make
every year I can assure you they can
afford it take it on it's within their
best interest I think to do so to ensure
that this program is successful but I
would also say that three years in now
we are starting at least in the
conversations that I'm having I won't
speak for cassia Rich we are starting to
see organic growth we're starting to
hear from people who enrolled because
they know of a family member or a friend
or another member of the community that
they've had a conversation with that's
had a good experience with this product
and so that's Peak their interest to
pursue it for themselves or for their
businesses so will it have an impact
sure now again does that mean we can't
account for that I think we I think we
can and I think that some of it at this
point has its own momentum in that
organic growth is going to kick in and
result in the program's growth over the
next several years and Beyond it's
repres thank you um just looking at the
effective date 60 days after Passage
would it make sense to delay it to
January 1 of next year is there any
benefit um and uh second part of the
question would be let's say this passes
tomorrow and there's contracts that
still need to be paid There's No
Interruption um anticipated CH cass's
got that one so
um I think it makes sense to um either
so what I'm thinking about is the budget
process right right so when when I'm
going to assume when they just normally
flip this over to flip the into the
first hb1 and
hb2 well I think what they're going to
do in in the accounting unit for paid
family medical leave in the dis budget
is is zero it out okay they're just
going to zero it out right right that's
the operations expense what I mean by
that is as I've talked to you folks it's
a it's our consultant it's our marketing
it's the website Etc it's not the state
employee benefit expense that's being
debated okay so once the once the
contract's unfunded I'm going to notice
our contractors that the contract is
been unfunded and there's a provision in
all state contracts that say that
they're dependent on funding so um I I
think that
um I would either leave the effective
date the way it is or upon passage is
what I would
recommend and I would say out of those
list of things the only thing that would
give me any uh great concern and again I
have a different perspective than Cassie
because she's more intimately involved
in these pieces but uh losing the
website I think would be a a real
challenge I think it would be so not
great at all um
not ideal far less than ideal I I'll put
it to you that way but if that was truly
something that the various Finance
committees felt was appropriate I think
I'd probably get to work to see how we
might be able to help with that okay all
right so we'll just leave it like this
then representative Gibbs thank you and
thank you for coming in to testify um so
this amendment would repeal the future
marketing a lot of the marketing has
already been done and the benefit will
remain
you okay thank you Mr chairman thank you
oh one more question repres helping
thank you chair uh how much is the cost
of the website it shouldn't be that much
and we really need something to tell
everybody we cannot just call everybody
and say that we have this PL send the
flyer it it it's quite minimal again
it's it's again you stand it up right
it's the work is done now now we have to
just refresh it from time to time so
it's it's like less than $100,000 our
current contract amount and um when when
commissioner beton Court said he'd be
happy to help I'm thinking maybe he'd
help maybe commissioner goule might help
so that we could keep it standing do
people um sign up through the web page
yes we have so that's it's critical to
keep it I mean obviously that's the
portal representative H and you and I
have had this conversation we're in
agreement that you know one of the
things that always gives us great
anxiety when the topic comes up about
whether or not we should move to some
sort of a state-based exchange for the
individual Market is we've been in the
federal exchange for so long now that
the citizens of our state have gotten
comfortable and used to and familiar
with the current system it would
potentially be quite disruptive to move
away from that and so it's not to your
point it's not just a website per se
it's also the conduit by which they go
and get the coverage and so that's why
that particular piece is of such
concern and it was great because if
there was a problem it was theirs not
ours that too and there was a problem
when they first started it most
importantly they have to pay for it well
but then that was the whole argument of
the bill was going if we switch to
estate that's right we could potentially
save a million or two but okay have no
more questions so the motion
uh uh uh who I guess who wants to take
is anybody want to write the BL or
otherwise I'll do
it um okay so uh you want to do Anon
okay uh it this is that we'll be writing
doing this next
Wednesday okay but but we want you to
have it written ahead of
time any okay all right so
representative am and by represent pusc
moves the amendment number 649 any
discussion on the motion see none all
those in favor raise their
hand six seven eight nine okay uh
represent Ammon second by representative
spear moves to pass as amended any
discussion on the motion seeing none all
those in favor raise your hand
2 3 four 6 n and we're good to
go and we're done look at that who
thought who think we could actually do
one two three four five s 10 11 12 12
half
e
started thank
all right so who is here in support of
this
Bild don't all chip over
yourself
okay don't you come on up here
good morning afternoon how are you
great it's nice to see you all um so we
already submitted this this is for our
work session correct correct so just
jogas what what's what was the problem
you want us to solve okay so this is
about you know trying to find those
bottlenecks we all know I think we've
heard from most of our constituents who
try to get mental health care about the
lack of mental health care in the state
um certainly and one of those parts is
um not is uh the in access to
credentialing getting that through not
making it easier to get credentialed but
certainly finding the the areas that are
causing some stricture in getting
credentialed and this was just one of
the areas
so sorry this tell us tell us a give us
a a a story of a problem what what are
we what is the problem we're trying to
fix here so um I'll go back to my
original so it's the current the current
Law requires Health carriers to
credential primary care physicians
within 30 days of receiving an
application in this bill would extend
that requirement to mental health care
providers so we already have something
on statute where we said we understand
that Health Care Providers can be within
30 days but currently trying to remember
how long it can take for mental health
care providers but it's certainly not
within those 30 days so we're wanting
this to shrink this down to within 30
days like it is for the other Healthcare
practices so you want to mandate that
uh because we we have this network
adequacy statute that requires that
health insurance companies have an
adequate Network which often we've heard
complaints that when it came to mental
health that it wasn't well covered or
there was some there but you're saying
is that that the insurance company is
dragging it feet and getting
conventionally done for mental
sorry let me I'm just reading to make
sure um so yes this is yes okay so yes
great sorry thank you very much so we're
all set perfect thanks don't go far stay
right here in front don't go in the back
of the room here stay close all right
and if you really want to you can pull
up a seat and have a
microphone yeah because this is a work
session um so I was now going to have
the insurance department to tell us
their interpretation of what this bill
okay thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee so depending on how
efficient you want to be I can speak to
both 507 and 706 let's just stick to one
one at a time that's perfectly fine so I
had originally testified on a house bill
506 and my view was that section one of
that bill 507 I'm sorry 507 so section
one of House Bill
507 is something that we support I
supported as commissioner I think that
is good to move forward I think anything
that we can do to ease the pipeline of
mental health providers into the system
is something worthwhile we obviously
have the demand and the need for it
throughout the state so if there's
something that we can do to ease that
process that's something that we're in
favor of going from
uh 45 days which is what mental health
providers are currently operating under
in terms of being credentialed once
there's a clean incomplete application
to 30 I don't think is terribly
disruptive to uh the industry and again
could potentially be very helpful to
getting more uh practitioners out there
being able to serve the public the
second half of the bill is something
that we as a department want to continue
to have a
dialogue with the stakeholders on
because what it seeks to do is to
retroactively allow those individuals
who are going through the credentialing
process to be able to retroactively bill
that seems straightforward the problem
is that the way it practically works is
that either credentialing happens first
and then Contracting to get in network
or the credentialing and the Contracting
processes take place Sim simultaneously
so the issue that comes up is all right
you're credentialed within the 30 days
you're good to go there but you have not
yet reached agreement or come to terms
on what your in network contracted rates
are going to be so what do you
retroactively build to and that's where
there's still a little bit more work
that needs to be done I'm not saying
that there's not a good solution that
could be brought to bear to deal with
that issue it's just an issue that I
think needs a little bit more discussion
a little bit more attention a little bit
more thinking through all of that which
I'm committing to the committee and to
the stakeholders that we will do over
the course of the next year and very uh
potentially very well likely there may
be supplemental legislation to come
before you all uh next year once we're
fully hash that out so those are my
thoughts on House Bill 507 okay
represent spear this is this is not an
early bill this bill is due on March
20th correct is there a time to do
something before March
20th your rules are your rules it's got
an FN so I don't know if it's an early
bill or not not really I mean I've seen
you do stuff
overnight oh
jeez okay I'm staying out of this so so
here here yeah to just jog everybody's
memory um so technically this bill has
to be out of committee next Thursday a
week from Thursday right is that correct
my Mathes right about the
20th did they
12th so what that means is everything we
do
today uh if we want to amend it we have
to figure out what the amendment's going
to look like and we will take it up on
Tuesday next
week and then come Wednesday we'll
execute so any amendments we do we want
to make sure they're short and sweet and
easy and I'm missing my researcher at
the moment so and I I don't even have a
copy of I have a copy of the bill so I
can
see so the most important part of the
bill is getting them credentialed in 30
days so my feeling is an easy Amendment
would be to just take out section two
there you go now see we that's why we
have you in a seat with a
microphone are you okay with that I
think that would work um I would need to
make sure but I think that's definitely
doable okay all right thank you all
right representative Burrows thanks I
just have a quick question what's and I
know we probably covered this what's the
definition of a clean application so all
of the information that the
credentialing application calls for is
fully completed all of the sections have
the supporting documentation needed
everything is in its proper order okay
so that would include let's say and this
happens somebody has a criminal record
that would have been that's part of you
know you that is absolutely one of the
else I was going to get him up okay so
uh the suggestion is that we just uh
remove paragraph 2 to and leave the
effective date to take 60 days after
fine maybe
not you want to have a January 1
okay I knew that was coming I just knew
that was gonna
so all right
all right so we
delete
two
two uh
date
January
1 20 26
okay is that everyone in the room
anybody have any other comments other
than those two
changes then we're all set thank you
very
much
okay
um I guess I mean in terms of taking a
straw vote right so I is there anybody
have a problem with those those changes
on but I'm back on 507 so we you just
say we discussed a potential Amendment
and and moving section two and changing
okay so speak now for more anybody have
275 all
right
uh is this your
bill I I know you might find it hard to
believe but I would lose my mind if I
numbers 7-Eleven I can do
7-Eleven I can sell all health insurance
goes goes back to 7-Eleven but after
that boy if I start I like I can't
remember build numbers so I my cheat
sheet just so you know my little cheat
sheet I pull out every Bill two key or
three key words and that's how I run on
it so this one is uh health insurance
credential
requirements which it just felt like I
just did mental health credentialing
well and now we're doing another
credentialing bill so unlike uh mental
health I think if more mental health
workers return phone calls we'd have
less problems but that's on a side note
um we spoke about House Bill 275 I think
it was last Thursday during or after
Chambers or in on break and I I provided
you with a letter from one doctor I have
two more coming you had said where are
the doctors in this and this one doctor
who happens to be a colonel in the the
uh New Hampshire National Guard but also
an active physician gave a rather nice
layout on the fact that he's got no time
for this training that these uh
insurance companies want him to do okay
it takes away time with patience but it
also increases the cost uh for his
practice depending on how broad the
want so what was he trying to be and
what and what was the uh course they
wanted him to take well the one was with
my dentist and I got an inquiry but the
dentist they wanted all four locations
that they have before they would be uh
considered uh uh C certify certification
with the insurance company to have all
of their staff being trained on LGBT EQ
plus
training now I think everybody's teeth
my dad was a dentist everybody's teeth
are the same unless they fall out or
there's a problem so I don't get that
but anyway the the insurance company
probably required it for their ESG score
but it really goes further than
that is if there's other training that
these people have to have they have to
pay for it if the insurance company want
them to do it and uh they go through um
undergrad they go through medical school
they do residency they have to be board
certified which all have courses and
requirements and costs associated with
it so now the insurance companies comes
back and says well we want you to take
this course well and and I know you
folks are very concerned about the costs
that insurance companies occur but if
they want this course to be taken I view
it as a cost of doing business and to
and and actually to go one step further
it's probably less expensive for the
cons consumer because they'll be more
insures to pass this cost that they want
instead of just being on a physician or
a dentist or any other health care
provider so it's more than just the the
example that I gave you it deals with
the fact that these people don't have
the time in the day how long does it
take to get a doctor's appointment these
days I mean I'm I'm five weeks out to
get my back treated so I could walk
without pain for the last two years five
weeks for a procedure that's less than
an hour hour so let's send the doctor to
some training that may or may not have
anything to do with his practice of
medicine or
Dentistry just because they want it fine
pay for it that's all it's that
simple nothing's that simple but yes
representa spear one of the com one of
the comments that we have is that the
RSA that this thing is is in may not be
the right RSA did we ever find out what
it Mr chairman can I uh add to that this
is not a hearing this is a conversation
oh okay well I talked I remembered that
too officer representative and I went
back down to OS and I talked to the
person who drafted the bill and I
thought she did a very good job in
locating the credential uh she said no
this whenever you credential a doctor It
Gos into that statute I said okay well
there was some concern in the committee
but she reassured me that that's she
said that's that's the right statute to
where it go so um that was what their
concern was and I think there was
another concern about Obamacare and I
think I sent all of you the example I
gave you was adult Dentistry which
doesn't fall under the Affordable Care
Act pedi uh Pediatric Dentistry does but
this really I don't really see this
being Germaine if the insurance
companies have to follow a specific
business or they could just simply say
no we you you're not eligible to be in
our Network and have a nice day and go
find some other insurance but but again
Mr chairman the patient then is the one
who is yeah if you were if you're with
an insurance company you change
insurance and then there's a potential
procedure being done and you're changing
insurance companies and that new one
doesn't cover them what do you do oh you
got to get off the operating table
because your insurance company wants me
to have this training and okay I'm just
saying hypothetically that's not that's
not a good hypothetical no if
if so I guess the the issue and maybe we
can have the providers but but when I
read this statute regardless of what you
dropped in I'm just reading the actual
statute sure it they have the health
carriers credentialing verification
standards so that means they require it
of everyone not just this one doctor yes
correct and standards and to prevent
Health Care from utilizing separate
additional criteria in selecting
Healthcare professionals with whom it
contracts so it has to have a standard
set of criteria correct rules MH and
that's they require that of everyone
MH
so if
if XYZ health insurance company has a
requirement
that this other practice doesn't have
you they either get it
done or they just don't get take that
insurance anymore well the implication
here is they wouldn't take not you take
it anymore you haven't been able to take
it because you haven't been credential
to to begin with right but the
credentialing from this point for would
be something over and above the normal
credentialing process for example I
don't see that I what I read in here is
that that that they can they have to
have
standards and and that's it sure think
anander sure it also says that the
carrier will be responsible for paying
for it that's that's the bold face
that's the that's his that's that's the
new I'm I'm looking at the in the
regular print that's the the current law
and the current law I just don't
understand you know what the problem
being is if if he's now chosen your
physician this dentist EV or a physician
okay or a physician yeah and that um and
it's not the the physician's practice
has never been in had this insurance
company before no that's not true well
that's what I'm saying is so did did
that the company changed their standard
their criteria CR they changed their
criteria y so on the in the middle of
the game they they said oh by the way we
now require this correct and you're
saying that's fine but they should pay
for it exactly and the representative
over here said her hands up and I don't
want to interrupt her yes okay
representative
Gibbs thank you um was there any
anything further you wanted to say okay
thank you
um okay this bill um requires that if
there's additional uh credentials
required by the insurance company
presumably something beyond their
standard credentials or beyond what they
required when the physician originally
signed up with the insurance company um
the insurance company would have to pay
for it correct so that would solve your
payment problem but but it it appears um
that it would not solve the time problem
the time needed for all for the
physician and all the physician's
employees who attend the training
correct so could you elaborate on that a
little bit well my fa my late father was
an orthodontist so I know what it's like
for a professional and their time um and
I'm lucky because my physician a lots me
time even calls me back so um but uh
it's it's a hard one to I mean that's
one of the decisions like going back to
the dentist they had four locations they
would had to train all four locations
and the the impact of their business
would be hard to Fathom I mean so are
you recommending an amendment to this
bill to cover the time issues I'm not
I'm just saying is that that let the
insurance companies paid for whatever
the cost of the the education
is thank you thank you may may I ask
the nature of these trainings that they
require can can you elaborate on the
nature of these training that they
require you besides the standard well I
I just used the example of what my
dentist had been through but I'm sure
there's other demands placed on healthc
care providers too and and if you read
the letter from uh Dr Kelly I mean it
basically says that he doesn't have
enough time to do this but if it's
required for him to do it from is it
mostly administrative in nature most
uh requiring to adhere to protocol or
what what what's the nature of these
training they require when I asked him
about additional training he said that
when they become board certified
addition there's some additional
training but that's part of his ability
to become a physician in whatever
specialty is okay like Cardiology or or
you know neurology or whatever the case
may be um I just don't want an insurance
company to tell our healthc care
providers that they have to have
training before and insured like any of
us can go go to your doctor your dentist
or whatever because they want that
coverage you know and it's funny too is
I remember Mr chairman is you hate
putting additional requirements on
insurance companies because it then puts
more cost to everybody else that gets
Insurance well this is the opposite this
is the insurance companies doing
mandates trying to tell the doctors what
to do so and let the doctors pay for it
instead of them that's exactly what's
happening it's the exact opposite what
you don't like to see so what's the
reasoning I mean there must some
reasoning the insurance company gives to
you what is the reasoning behind the
insurance company then they Pro they ask
you to adhere to those additional
trainings ad I'm sorry adhere to what is
the reasoning Behind These additional
training that the insurance company
tells you to do it I can't speak for the
insurance company like the one the one
with a dentist must have been for their
ESG score to make sure that they are you
know capable and Avail doing what they
think is is socially right
can we get the insurance companies to
tell us a little bit about what kind of
require just just generically to respond
it doesn't matter what kind of training
it is it just just wait wait wait wait
wait in other words to to be a physician
in this state there's certain
requirements there there's undergrad
there's medical school there's
residency is Pixie Dust um protol that's
a doorbell that's a doorbell yeah the
the uh so so there there's a host of
Education that these people go through
um but the point that I'm trying to make
is is regardless of what the educational
requirement they have if they're
requiring a certified physician or a
dentist that has gone through oplc by
the way which is its own challenge um
then U then if they want it they should
pay for it that's it we got it you've
said it three times so we got it have a
seat over here please well you want to
ask you're going to ask a question go
ahead is it your position that um if the
insurance companies are are required to
pay for the training that that might um
discourage them from making additional
requirements that might not be directly
relevant to the practice of medicine or
Dentistry one would hope that yes that
that would be a great way of putting it
yes thank you oh thank you okay John can
I just say something quick yes yes thank
you you know we can't vote on something
like this unless we know what the
training is about any I agree no no but
but that that that's not good enough to
say any I need to know what it
is yeah okay so let me let me humor you
before we get too far we get the
insurance companies is as I further read
this
paragraph I will start with the very
first phas phrase and I say this only
because Jack you were saying how about
what I don't like okay with this
paragraph if I read it
correctly is is uh saying is the health
insurance company has the right to say
we don't want you as a
physician okay and that if just because
they have met the standards in their
plan doesn't mean they have to take you
in that's what I read the first sentence
to say there it has a very famous word
for us in this committee
solely and solely is a very important
insurance criteria because it means that
that just because one thing may be true
it does not mean the whole thing can't
be true well I I so I can see why
someone would say that adding this
little sentence on here onto something
about whether they're willing to accept
you or not into their their practice is
problematic well then I go over here and
I look at the FIS the uh fiscal note
here and the department says oh by the
way
any
any additional Health Care uh additional
program or certification it says well
how who's to Define that who knows what
which one is any okay and as you just
had with with representative Burrows
well you know come on are they asking
something that's like oh and above
totally inappropriate are they asking
something that really is a new
credential that they now require of all
their patients other Physicians
hopefully I'll be able remember the
three question let me share a word with
you that we have on the labor committee
it's called
discrimination in other words these
people are licensed by the state okay
they go through it education process
they go through residency and ultimately
the oplc provides them with a license to
become a physician a dentist or whatever
the case so they're all qualified okay
so if what you're saying is true is that
then the insurance companies are picking
and choosing who they're having on their
plan someone could argue the fact that
because they didn't want to take that
course that they are discriminating
against however this bill says well if
they want them to take their course then
they will pay for it okay okay so hate
to tell you this but health insurance is
all about
discriminating okay the Managed Care
model was built around who was going to
be in the network and who is not correct
that you could direct that you're going
to set up the
premiums the payments to that provider
based upon the amount of volume you're
going to send that patient that doctor
okay and so yes there's absolutely just
we hear it all the time that some uh
position some providers can't get in the
network chairman can I make a comment
can I can I make a comment on the so as
with any profession as the time goes by
the requirements and protocols do evolve
and keep changing so unless we know the
details of what kind of training this
insurance company are mandating and
what's the reason behind that uh I don't
think we have enough information to to
even go further that who should pick up
the tab or it shouldn't because it have
because it might be required for
conducting business in a in a in a in a
current environment that they they
required so that would be my comment I
have a question
yes I don't know
if the requirement for various extra
over and above training especially some
of the training that's been mentioned
ever came from the state of New
Hampshire as opposed to the federal
government down on
Medicare we have no regulations that we
can do on Medicare requirements or
anything like that
so we has New Hampshire can we find out
that has New Hampshire ever put anything
like this on anybody okay so
um yeah so before I go uh uh
DJ you guys recommend retaining this
bill is that is do I have my notes
correct on this no different different
belill okay this is a different Bel but
I can speak quickly on okay all right
this is the legal council this is the
legal council for the insurance
department okay so Michelle Heaton
director of life and health um when we
had testified on us on this previously
we raised the concern that the way it's
drafted is extremely Broad and it could
include anything from any kind of
continuing education we also pointed out
that um it has always been the process
that the carrier determines what their
credentialing standards are those are
all usually above licensing requirements
which is the bare minimum so it's up to
them to figure out what they wanted each
company can choose their own and they
can apply whatever they want and I think
in T I would just um punt it over to the
carriers now but I believe in testimony
we did hear some testimony particularly
from Sabrina if she's here about this
particular issue and um the example that
was I do remember that okay so rever G
giv do you have a question for the
insurance department or would you want
to make it to an insurance company more
a question for you actually Mr chair
okay um okay I understand the um idea of
hearing from the insurance company about
what kind of training or whatever they
require but they're all as was just said
they're all private companies and they
can all decide for themselves right and
very I mean I'm sure they're not all
identical so are we going to call them
all in how can we handle that uh well we
only have three but so but uh uh at this
point um there are more than willing to
tell you why they don't like this bill
so I guess what I want to weed out is
other
than the sponsor is there anybody in the
committee that's really interested in
knowing whether we should keep going
down this path of this bill and learning
more about it or are we ready to uh kill
it um represent can I raise a what if so
what if a a new procedure uh for I don't
know for treating the heart came uh came
on y wouldn't an insurance company
say wouldn't it be allowed to say to a
physician um in order for you to do this
procedure we want to make sure that
you've got this additional training
would that be unfair for the insurance
company to ask that what most insurance
company would say is we're not going to
pay for it
to new procedures however if you have an
issue with Mr chairman if you have an
issue with the uh language of the the
bill itself so where it could be
incorporated in the existing credential
I'd be more than happy to talk to you
about that and say we can but um you're
going to have to save that for another
year because basically the issue the
issue here is this the language of this
amendment the way you've written the way
the Bill's written right um when you
start if you get Beyond any additional
and then you're going to try to figure
out some language about what was the
rationale for the insurance company to
add for this different credentialing
standard I think one of the what I'm
just hearing from all the committee
members is that the insurance companies
are are free to set their standards and
set what they want to make their
requirements to be and so therefore why
would you step why would we step into
trying to figure out referee which ones
they should pay
for uh or which ones they they just say
they think you should have it because
the doctors only have so much time in
the day that is not a good excuse I'm
sorry so when all Physicians have to do
continue education I got that okay and
it's usually for betterment of their
their practice but I'm just saying it at
what point in time do we say enough is
enough too because I don't want to wait
for a
doctor I it's not us to say uncle it's
the insurance companies to decide what
they think is appropriate and what is
not
oh yes yes
okay that's a good excuse at least it
was your name and not some slang word
that I've heard my
name thank you um Sabrina Dunlap senior
director of government relations for
Anthem I just wanted to refresh memories
because this was a while ago the
anecdote that was used when the bill was
introduced involved uh an Anthem
Medicare Advantage plan and a contractor
that we contracted with who administered
a basic training that was required under
federal law they were following CMS
guidelines so I just want to be very
clear that that's what was discussed
originally with the hearing that was the
basis for the bill apparently um and so
I just want to be clear we're sort of
talking about one thing over here but
the bill was based on not even an
insurance company it was a contractor
that we used in the Medicare Advantage
space in the dental space that was
simply following CMS rules and it was
around culturally and linguistically
appropriate services to make people feel
more comfortable in the office something
like that so I just wanted to level set
that that's what we were talking
about thank you for the opportunity to
clarify okay don't go away no no we're
all said Jack no it adult denry is not
part of
Obamacare okay Federal we're talking
about this is about we actually know a
little bit about Medicare Advantage now
we've been all boned up on that now so
you're you're all said Jack okay um who
would like to make a motion for
inexpedient to legislate not me
representative
burrow
okay
representative Burrows oh she yeah she's
on the health kid Y and then second by
uh who else me just me just put me
okay all right so the the uh health
insurance subcommittee is Peli miles
Cole hunt Teresa Gibbs and
spear okay so we got seven seven of us
all those in favor of inexpedient to
legislate raise your hand one two three
four I I just want to ask one last
question before
I we're in the voting mode okay okay uh
Cole's Cole's missing yeah okay so it's
six six zip so what is your question
well I mean the question was that uh so
we are iing it because we don't have
enough information about the reason why
insurance companies ask that the those
details do if we don't really need to
know that okay we don't know there at
the end of the day that these
requirements in in the cas that started
the bill was obviously a CMS requirement
it was Federal requirement but that you
know if there is a um uh additional
requirements some insurance company is
going to come up with something then
then that's their right they mandate
basically they can they can have their
standards and we would assume that they
do their standards
intentionally so that they can maintain
their
status okay okay all right so we need
me itl okay next one
audits two we is that one we just
did we just did
okay okay so a six all right provider
this is the one you guys want to kill
right
no why my notes all
wrong oh this is the audits right this
is the one this is the one we want to
retain because oh yeah this is the one
we got the federal the feds haven't
haven't haven't really sung yet right
they're still no that's our data bill
that's later that's a data bill you guys
are handing too many bills today seem
all the same to me okay I'm here to help
hopefully I don't make it anyse here
Jack audits with respect to House Bill
706 okay I'll offer a friendly
suggestion and then okay obviously you
all do what you feel is best I
appreciate the fact that you've got a
little bit of queasiness at this point
to retain any more legislation my
suggestion would be though to make an
exception for this bill and I will give
you my reasons so because we've had to
be involved with so many pieces of
legislation this session both House and
Senate I did not have the opportunity to
touch base with the stakeholders who
have prompted House Bill 706 to be
brought forward until just this past
Monday I was initially confused as to
what the bill was seeking to address
because when I think of audits we
frequently hear from providers who tell
us that they really struggle both
operationally and from a financial
standpoint to deal with audits of claims
some of which stretch back several
months but typically it's the case that
the audits happen and again what we hear
most frequently are complaints about the
audits that happen post payment so the
service has been rendered the payment
has been delivered and then some period
after that there's an audit and some
sometimes there's actually a clawback of
the funds that have already been paid
associated with that and the provider
struggle to work through that
process so conceptually when I read this
bill for the first time and saw audits I
was thinking to myself I've not really
heard of there being a predominant
problem where the service has been
rendered but you're in that interregnum
period between the service being
rendered and then the payment being
received I got further clarification as
to what the bill is actually trying to
address as I said earlier this week and
what it appears to be speaking to are
the practices of some carriers that are
innovating around the prepayment review
process that as I understand it is truly
the pain point that the providers are
trying to address through this bill so
prepayment review and I'm going to
grossly simplify this and the carriers
can or my team can get into further the
detail if you would like the prepayment
review process is when the carrier sees
that there's a particular provider who's
an outlier for some reason they're
really billing a code much more
frequently over and above similarly
situated providers and they want to
understand why and so there'll be a
little bit of an investigation that will
go through that but they'll put them on
prepayment review which says that it's
almost a quasi but not quite prior
authorization type process which says
before we're going to agree to pay you
we need to understand exactly what it is
you're doing what it is you plan to
build
for uh and there you know in its most
extreme form it's a fraud prevention
measure to ensure that providers are not
billing inappropriately either through
innocent mistake or they just need
further education but also to ensure
that providers are not abusing the
system my understanding is that again
there's been some Innovation with that
prepayment review process and it's
manifested itself in a place where
providers aren't really able to
understand why they're in prepayment
review they don't know how to get out of
it it's being applied seemingly um
predominantly in areas where there are
Mental Health Services being rendered
that are not subject to any sort of a
prior authorization review process due
to Pia predominantly and so there are
some issues that again have just been
brought to our attention recently I'd
like the opportunity to understand more
hear from more providers exactly what's
playing out here and that may very well
result in this bill being brought
forward in a different fashion we may
need to put some safeguards around that
process I just don't know yet I I need a
little bit more information I need to
hear from a few more providers uh as to
what their experience is if there's a
similar experience that they're having
if there's a trend that's beginning to
develop so respectfully if you're
willing it would be I think beneficial
for the Department to work with those
stakeholders throughout the course of
the summer and fall and be able to
report back to you in September uh what
out so they're uh requesting that we
retain the bill so they can come back
with something that that seems to
address the issue ises that sound okay
with you represent gr okay anybody have
a problem with retaining this
bill
okay uh we can do that right now uh so
the subcommittee all those in favor of
retaining uh hb76 please raise your hand
anyone 70 7
room still
is there was one two
it
Burrows
okay on
oh
okay all right this is this is my my
ambulance bill right I got the right
Bill okay so this is the one we want to
pass because this is the one the
department has done all the hard work on
it and we've had some mates and you want
to make the motion I want
I participated in the
um ambulance in the uh in the
yesterday and other than coming away
depressed what I saw and what I
heard was a
problem in understanding the scope of
what this committee can do so there is
Ambulance Service provided to Medicare
patients orisa
patients Medicaid
patients and patients under uh what do
we call it um fully insured
market and this committee only has
control over what is legislated and
regulated for the fully insured Market
and I think there
was so so we can't fix the whole problem
all we can fix or at least work on is
market
and and while I and while that's the
smallest piece of this whole thing
that's all we've
got and so we expect to see more bills
coming maybe we can do a bill for
Medicaid we can't control anything with
Medicaid
talk well then I I don't know what we
can do I want to make a comment too yeah
well that's not totally correct we
they're I thought we can I make a
comment we do regulate the supplements
can I can I make a comment sha so I
think we discussed in detail last time
about 36 what we didn't discuss at all
was 725 and both those bills are going
to address the needs for ambulance
services so I would suggest that I mean
we should discuss this together and uh I
don't think you can pass both you have
to you have to pick one over another
correct so I should we discussed that in
conjunction to each other not like in in
in Silo so should we do it together
rather than voting on 36 then
725 I we generally try to avoid doing
that but if you want to discuss the
differences between the two we certainly
can talk about that represent miles has
a point of view on that doesn't she
now thank you Mr chairman um I do have I
do have grave concerns about 316 because
it it not only prevents them from
balanced billing but it also doesn't
give them the amount of money that they
verbalized would be adequate and so I
think that could cause more harm than
316 I'm I'm not sure I just I'm very
concerned that tell us about 725 what
why do you think 725 is the already
answer I think it is based on what the
EMS Chiefs and bureaus have all come and
testified about I think that's what they
have decided is adequate at this Point
yeah and I would agree with that's
that's what that's the point where I
wanted to mention that we should discuss
this together that way we know what's
the difference the only difference Bas
these two is 315 is giving you less than
200% 725 is giving you 3 25% which is
what the ambulance uh companies uh they
their feel is adequate and also the fire
CH understand that
325 is basically expecting the uh the
12% who have private insurance to make
up that the the 12% was the three 316
the dollar amount that it should be
appropriate for that group to be paying
but that 3 725 says we're going to
disregard that we don't care we think
people who have private insurance should
pay to make up for what we don't get
from Medicare and Medicaid which are the
80%
of the users of the ambulance can we
step back a little can we step back a
little before we go to the uh premium
part of it uh so I mean I I know
chairman you like small short stories so
let just give you a small story is that
suppose somebody is in a ER and the
doctor prescribes that person needs you
know 325 mL of oxygen to get back on
feet while then the hospital gives only
200% of oxygen while it could be a
little bit helpful but it's not going to
achieve the goal what the doctor that's
the reason why hospitals are highly
subsidized by the state to make so that
was just that just an example in this
case repeatedly the ambulance department
and also the fire chiefs they have test
they have given testimony they have
expressed that in order for them to
operate productively or operate uh
properly they probably would need 3 25%
of of the Medicaid uh Medicare need not
200% while 200% might give them
something but that might not be adequate
uh for them to operate now coming back
to your point of Premium I heard last
time that uh uh the bill 316 is going to
raise $4 to for the insurance person per
per year while $725 will increase to $7
that's a differ $3 per year per person
for a family of four people that's $12
for the year which is a dollar per month
now I don't think dollar per month $4
per
person so that if you're a family of
four it's now $16 yes that okay so I'm
mean dollar something per month so you
know I don't think that's a big jump in
premium a dollar something per month to
uh to negate this and the second thing I
would like to say is that in general
insurance companies they make amount of
profit okay another thing that you need
to know that under the Affordable Care
Act insurance company's
profitability is
capped and that it is
limited to
10% so that means they they can and they
sh a premium when they charge in a
premium 90% of that premium is
predetermined by a three-year average of
look back on what they paid out to
Providers the remaining 10% covers all
their costs marketing their people their
personnel the paper pushing all the
bureaucrats and then maybe somewhere in
there they can find a profit that is
under law okay so even if the insurance
company is going to pass on all the
expense to the to its members as you
rightly said in before that the proposal
that you are proposing 360 is going to
raise $4 versus 725 bill is going to
increase $7 it's a differ of $3 per
person and that's for for a family of
four that's $12 per for the dollar a
month this is ambulance now so do you
think we should be charging all these
same people who have insurance shouldn't
we may have them be charging to make up
for the fact that the doctors are not
are getting underpaid or the hospitals
are being underpaid how where are you
going to stop why are you just picking
ambulance out of the blue and say ooh
that's the one that they need to pay
Medicare and Medicaid for why don't you
just choose everything just why don't we
just make all the people with private
insurance just pay for all the health
insurance costs because Medicare
Medicaid won't pay for it yeah let me
respond to that so I mean one thing is
that you know first of all we're
addressing the ambulance need but coming
to your point when the medical
facility uh sends a bill they usually
get 60% of of what they bill from the
from the insurance company they don't
get 20% Which is Medicare rate as per
the ambulance bill they get about 60% of
the bill paid by the insurance so
insurance companies are already paying
about 60% of the doctor's Bill to them
in general they they don't pay 20% you
know they never pay 20% of the bill to
the doctors or to the hospitals but if
they are paying 20% of the bill to
ambulance servic as we agree they're
already paying the largest portion than
anybody else they're paying more than
Medicare more than Medicaid more than uh
even orisa but how much is more when you
say more what you just said 60 no I said
60% for the doctors and hospitals we
talking about ambulance if the ambulance
is asking that give me 0% can I of the
bill I think you made your point all
right that representative Gibbs has her
hand up next thank you um okay uh we
can't touch orisa or Medicare those are
entirely Federal Medicaid assuming we
could touch anything um we could touch
only the state portion but that's really
going to be controlled by the governor
um and the finance committee so there's
probably very little that the Commerce
and we have no money right to do about
it yeah
um so um during the public hearing I
found the ambulance providers believable
um and as I believe I said said during
the public hearing uh therefore I prefer
um
725 um however um if uh the provisions
of
316 are um uh the consensus of the
committee and if that is what is most
likely to pass I would would be willing
to go along with that um I did uh listen
to the Consulting company's
presentation um uh on M is one that um
representative spear was talking about
yes uh and and that's where 316 comes
from and honestly I was not impressed um
it was all numbers no evaluation no
analysis no reason why they made the
conclusions that they did so I I was
just not impressed by it I understand
were you there or you you listen to you
sorry you did it virtually uh virtually
yes okay they they did explain exactly
why they put the number that they paint
in I I was very I was completely
opposite I mean yes I was listening on
the phone but they see they delve deep
into and and how they did the exclusions
and how they did the numbers and yes I
thought I thought they did a very good
presentation so I'm sorry you you were
not impressed their explanation was all
numbers okay well that was what the
whole what I was hoping to hear for was
something articulated as in we we
decided on this number because after for
considering factor a factor B and factor
C we also considered this other number
but we decided against it because there
was nothing like that no that's we
didn't want that we told them we want to
know what it does it really cost for
private insurance companies to so that
they're that for these ambulance
companies what should be in a vacuum you
could say as in a vacuum we're saying
we're taking the Medicare and beend the
you know just the the clients who are
actually there what would the number be
and it came in at
202 what three% over Medicare so and and
the Medicare number was only that's only
that's a moving Target number obviously
because Medicare number was FL so but
they just did that to give us some
mathematical you know combination how to
uh you know do it because because of the
other bill was
325 over Medicare and that number was as
it seemed was literally as you just said
out of the air okay there was no
rationale to the
325 okay your this bill the 315 was B 16
was built on being rational exactly what
it really insurance company should be
reimbursing it as far as as far as I was
concerned um the providers did provide a
rationale
um and the consulting
company provided numbers
got it okay okay okay they did not
articulate for you you wanted a little
more articulation rather the numbers um
okay what I'm look can I finish what I'm
considering doing in the committee but
not in the full house um would be voting
in favor of both 316 and 725 so that the
full house um can give full
consideration to
both there is no doubt that all bills
can come to the
floor uh but if I have my brothers what
I would like to be seeing is that that
316 is going to be ought to pass and and
7 so 25 would be inexpedient to
legislate and yes you can get up on the
floor and fight to overt term that I
understand that um and we have discussed
this before and as I said I was willing
to go along with
316 um but I'm still not entirely
comfortable got it yeah representative
miles
thank you uh so in the meeting on Monday
um the one thing that I did notice was
that uh in fact uh representative Gibbs
you mentioned uh they did not take into
account the three highest outliers in
their accounting um and then
separately um insurance companies pay
for a lot of things that don't do much
for the majority of their clients they
do something good for a few whereas this
would help the greater good and so 725
would help the greater good and so I
316 it would prevent them from balance
billing and they cited in Monday's
conference that what would happen if we
did this would be that they would
automatically have to start billing a
minimum of $500 to each uh ambulance
ride or or
whatnot for Trans for transport is that
that's what I heard
in but it was cited something like
something along those lines was cited no
only to the insured only to the insured
Medicare patients would not be hit with
the same billing right it was only for
the insured all talking about for
insured yeah so in in any case I just
think 316 is going to handcuff them more
than they're handcuffed now so does
725 take away balance billing it takes
away balance billing but it also
provides them with more Revenue right
but it does take away balance billing
also that's the only difference is that
amount right and it just it they're
they're the same in the sense that they
both both take away balanced billing yes
right but in in but in 725 they're just
making the that they're getting
the the the smallest GR small group who
uses it pay pay the Lion Share that's
Insurance they're getting that's
Insurance oh how about that's Medicare
Medicaid let's let's put the blame where
it we've listened to them over and over
and over they've asked for something and
it's our job to do the best for the
community and to our constituents okay
representative
speaker at the very beginning of the
meeting uh the insurance department came
up and made a discussion as to where the
data came from
and they talked about how they got it
from the data that was submitted by the
carriers every dollar was accounted for
it all came from the carriers it wasn't
like they came up with numbers out of
the air they took the carriers I mean
the um provids numbers they added an
inflation rate they did a a bunch of
analysis on on based on uh what kind of
service was provided it was an analysis
of what the folks sent in it wasn't made
up was all their numbers so the numbers
were a very good representation of what
it cost to provide the service
unfortunately it's only 8.7% of the
market and there's nothing we can do
about that we don't regulate any other
part of the market they did they did a
very good job with the numbers I'm not
arguing about that at all they explained
where the numbers came from the problem
that I had with it was that they never
articul culated their reasoning and
that's what I was looking for it was
real numbers it was numbers that were
they submitted they didn't have to
articulate their reason this was the
numbers they were handed by the
providers no one in EMS has supported
that they've all come they've all asked
for
325 to be adequate and is all they're
asking for and then we can all move on
no what they're asking for is to to
cover an area that we have no
responsibility for we don't deal with we
have a responsibility cover can I make a
comment see let me I just want to throw
one little piece in here okay I uh I
went in my town meeting yesterday we
have Senate Bill too and my town of
ringe voted
$36,000 for our ambulance shared
Ambulance Service Jeffrey family Jeffrey
and ringe ambulance service so when you
say that they want that number okay I
believe that they are getting the money
now okay because otherwise they would
have been out of business right they
would have gone out of business because
this issue's been around since I've been
here but the that they're all getting
money from the towns that they serve and
they are just like a fire department
okay can I so if you're not
if you are able not to build the town
and you they're scrambling if you can
get away without doing it all on balance
billing then I bet you you rather keep
balance billing and that's what I think
the problem here is is that the balance
billing is a very dangerous thing here
and that is that it has been around from
day one it's always been it it it's
something they use and I truly believe
they don't want to lose it at all so if
we send this bill 316 over to to the
Senate and the Senate wants us send us
basically 725 is the bill they have
right apprentice's Bill looks like or
your husband's bill look looks like
doesn't it look like that okay if that's
where we're going to get down to it then
balance billing will be the hot issue
and frankly it should be the ambulance
can choose the ambulance can choose to
continue to operate the way have they
have now or they can choose this model
that we're suggesting the 725 that that
also removes balance billing right that
both it it theoretically it removes
balance billing yeah so both the bills
they both the bills are addressing to
remove balance billing so both are
similar that bill look like what does
the Senate bill look like okay so here's
the thing is that what we charge the
insurance department with doing is
coming up with a rational
I'm sorry it doesn't fill the stories
for representative gids but it a
rational numeric calculation on what
insurance companies should be paying and
yes it absolutely is a mandate on them
absolutely they're going to be raising
their their rates already with this new
number okay the question was if we're
going to do this how do we make sure
that it's fair to those have that
insurance because you certainly don't
want to say is for everyone says well
screw it I don't want to I don't want to
buy insurance anymore I want to go on
you know you know Medicaid or I want to
go I want to do something else simply
because the legislature decided in its
wisdom that we're going to frontload and
make just people with small employer
insurance pay the Lion Share but we
already discussed only a dollar
difference between both the bills per
month
so that I'm saying is that's why the
203 is the best Bill to put forward
because it's definitely increase it's
definitely you know it's definitely an
in going to be a mandate it will raise
premiums but the end of the day it's
rational and we built into that model
that every two years they will be able
we're going to redo the numbers and
maybe they'll be more forthcoming with
their new numbers or something I don't
know maybe there will be a change but I
will guarantee you I'll bet you it'll be
a higher than 203 I'll bet you it will
go up okay so chairman can I let me hear
from you u f analysis on both 31 316 how
much is raes premium you said around $4
two what it was no the the hb31 316 what
what was the per member do we have a per
member
analysis I think the way it mentioned
was
$4 okay if I may I feel like I need to
correct to this when we're talking about
increases in premium and we do our
mandate study there is a a cost
associated with an increase in overall
health care costs and that's usually a
round dollar amount we then express it
as per member per month right but it it
would be incorrect to assume that any
increase in costs is going to result in
that exact per member per month increase
how rates are developed is a much more
intricate process and this is not an
even thing so it doesn't mean everyone's
rates go up a dollar per month per
member it can impact different groups
differently every carrier has its own
rating process based on their experience
and what they are experiencing for
claims for this it could have a greater
impact to certain groups over others so
I would just caution you when we're
talking per member per month that is a
bit of a misn number so if you look at
the fiscal notes for each one of these
and I'm sorry I don't think it got put
in correctly I'll have to pull it up
give me one second I can pull up we did
use the sa so the actuary firm that did
the cost study analysis they have used
that same methodology to do um analysis
for all of these bills so they are
comparable in that respect when we're
talking ballparks obviously these are
all estimates so if you give me one one
second I can pull up the exact analysis
so for 316
[Music]
I believe like the total impact was
so yeah for 316 the estimate is that the
total um cost associated with these
services will increase by 4.3 million
okay that total cost needs to be
absorbed in insurance premiums in some
way okay so for the other one which is
yes so for 7:25 it's it's estimated that
um it will cause a total increase in
costs by around 15 million yeah I see
that here on the fiscal note so so you
go from 4 million to 15 million yeah so
let uh so can I can I make a couple of
comments first of all the reason why we
even discussing both 316 and 725 is that
fundamentally all of us feel that
ambulance services they need help and
it's a very important life saving
service that we need to help to continue
that's one fact second thing both these
bills are going to increase the premium
so we are here for increase in in
premiums the third thing is that the
number that we are reading newshire
Association of Fire Chiefs last time
they presented this written testimony
they are coming I don't know how they
come with number but they come 36 cents
per member versus 50 cents per
member now we just heard 4.3 million to
15 million now if you just go by linear
you know computational
analysis you providing
200% help than Medicare cost that's 4.3
million 725 is only 35% which is like
100 just extra 35% more help than what
you're proposing so you are increasing
725 increases only 35% more help to
Ambulance Service than your previous
Bill 316 how the cost is going to become
four 4 fold by by only
increasing do you follow I'm
saying the the the 316 that you
proposing that pay only 200% of the
Medicare rate to Ambulance Service
that's going to increase 4.3 million
according to what just
heard now instead of
giving 200% money you are now giving 3
25% money 3 25% money is only less than
35% additional cost on top of 200% that
you're already giving so you're
increasing a pay out of
35% by the second Bill how that cost
increases
fourfold that I don't understand it
should be in linear because you follow
I'm saying I got $5 I give $7 how $5
will amount to 4.3 million versus $7
which is second bill will amount 15
million I don't understand where the
disconnect is I mean is a
I think I understand what you're saying
and part of um the estimates for this
impact is that you're talk we're
talking when we're saying a percentage
of Medicare the Medicare rates it's not
one rate there are depending on the
billing code there are a number of
different rates and each one of those
rates has a different amount associated
with it so the an Actuarial analysis is
using claims data to say you know
generally of all the ambulance claims
you know 40% of it is for this specific
code and this amount of money so that's
why it's totaling all of that so it's
not linear because each code has a
different um amount Associated I know
but the same code applies to 200% also
see in one case chairman wants to give
200% for the same codes is costing is
costing 4.3 million extra I want to give
315 3 25% which which is only 30%
increase of what he is proposing for the
same codes for the same billing Cod for
the same Services it's not like I'm
changing service here but you know just
a simple you know if you think simply
how ad just the increase of extra oneir
I mean it's one3 more 3 25% almost one3
more than 200% right you agree with that
right yeah so I'm giving one3 more for
the same Services how that will cost you
four times more than what you pay for
200% I mean I don't see I'm sure you
have done all the analysis and all the
numbers but these numbers just don't you
know make sense and I I can see where
you're coming from but it's it's not
that easy to um evaluate this and that's
why we could put on a spreadsheet
there's a way we can do a spreadsheet to
somehow show how how that occurred how
how with some calculations but I mean
that's why we contract with actuaries to
do these whole analyses and the more
more actual analysis we ask for the more
it cost the department money we try to
use it sparingly okay with the analysis
the same what you've done what is the
per what is the per person or per family
cost increase in both the cases do you
have that number we don't know that
because it that goes back to the
intricacies of rate making we're saying
overall healthcare costs are going to
increase by this million doll amount
whatever which plug in whichever
Millions you want four 15 which one do
you want to those the carriers then have
different makeups so every carrier has a
different book of business with
different people and different types of
plans and they need to adjust for how
that's going to impact their plans I
think there's a lot that goes into this
and it's not just what carriers are
going to pay it's also what um their
contracts with the the covered people
are going to pay because depending on
whether you have a bronze silver gold
Platinum level plan that's going to
impact your cost sharing so when we're
upping the rates for something it's not
just the amount that the carriers are
now responsible for paying it's also
increasing the amount the consumers
through their cost sharing will also be
required to pay so can can I
ask can you just you know
say yes you would like to see more
something more linear like more level
more rational that that because the
difference between
207 203 and 325 only looks like $120
more why why is it showing up as four
times more and also have I got it stated
correctly yes that's the question I have
I mean anybody can same question so
here's the problem here's the
problem we have to pass a bill okay and
the best we can do is ask the
Departments to give us some numbers now
if the numbers don't seem rational to
you not to me to anybody to anybody to
anybody then we can do nothing and that
is really what has happened in my entire
40 years on this
committee where ambulance has always
been a
problem and we ended up doing well we we
did direct
pay we didn't do much okay we've never
we we haven't really done anything so
therefore at the end of the day you have
to make a decision that you could say is
it doesn't seem rational that let's just
go with a higher number and and see what
happens gentlemen
I at some point in time we've got to we
got to pick we got to pick our poison
here could we hear one more time from
the gentleman from EMS that's been
having his hand up for a while um sir
here okay I have a couple of questions
and a couple of comments who who do you
have questions to um okay um uh first
one is um for you um for the Department
um your mic is not on I think oh I'm
sorry thank you um were you saying that
the variables that you mentioned um and
I I understand there are a lot of them
um that that was all taken into account
in figuring the 4 million and the 15
million yes the actuary that we contract
with did the analysis to estimate that
given the suggested rates or the rates
in whatever is being proposed in each
fiscal note given that rate what would
that do to overall health care costs so
they have I don't know exactly
everything that they did but they did of
it and gave us the numbers thank you
thank you okay I want to get away from
the numbers for a minute okay um I have
a couple of comments um there were three
things that made me feel better um about
316 to 725 one is the fact that 725
would clearly raise the premiums higher
than 316 would um correct okay the
difference between the amount of payment
to the providers would makes that clear
um the second is that under 316 there's
a review by the insurance department
every two years correct so they can take
into account what's happened between now
and then and uh come up with the new
figure and they can do that into the
future that wasn't in
725 um and then your argument Mr chair
about um trying to have this one small
part of the whole Market that we can
control make up for all the federal
underpayments I understood that um okay
uh the one thing that I feel strongly
about is getting rid of balance billing
and um I didn't quite understand what
you said earlier Mr chair um what were
you thinking that um the Senate it when
the Senate gets these bills that they
might amend um whichever one we pass to
put balance billing back in so that it
would be
allowed um I was suggesting that I have
a sneaking suspicion that uh some
ambulance companies don't want to let go
of balance
billing and that that it is the it's the
devil they know and and the devil they
they built their books around and
they've been operating all these years
so I was suggesting that um that if we
sent over 316 to the Senate that if that
they could make that a choice so that
would relevant to both the the ambulance
company can choose which way they want
to go so that that is a possibility that
the Senate will put balance billing back
in I assuming that the Senate is going
to send us back a bill that's going to
look very much like 725
that is my
suspicion okay um but with balance
billing or without it and I was just
saying is because that's way I am
sometimes is a compromise is is uh that
uh
because it's funny all along this issue
really comes down to the fact that that
most of these ambulance companies the
reason why they do the balance bilding
is because they don't want to uh take
the contract price from the insurance
company because they think it's too low
I got that part and so therefore if that
is really if we're going to get down to
where your choice is is that if you that
we're we're going to give you offer you
a choice that is going to quad know two
200 times more than what Medicare was
paying which obviously I'm sure I don't
know where the insurance companies came
in but let's say they were around more
like a 100 times over Medicare so we're
doubling doubling the potential check
but that that if they don't if they
still don't think that that's going to
be good because we took away balanced
billing then they should have the option
to stick with the balance billing and
stick with the way they've always
operated and that that would be a
potential compromise what what I'm
suggesting is that we should be fair to
the insurance companies customers and
the providers but one thing more than
that that we should avoid driving the
customers slash patients crazy and the
balance billing drives them crazy and I
don't think that's appropriate and and
and the reality is that you know the
federal government understood greed and
they fixed balance billing for
everything
except ambulances and so it's up to us
to fix
it okay thank you Mr
chairman so first of all I I want to lay
a couple things aside the New Hampshire
you wanted to introduce yourself sure my
name is Michael sear I'm the chief of
the Tilton norfield fire district a
small uh fire district protecting about
10,000
people um and we run a combination fire
department which means we have full-time
people it's mostly full-time people but
we have some uh um part-time people
called call Firefighters as well that
respond with us um we do about 2200 runs
a year and about uh 70% of those runs
are ems in nature so the simple way of
looking at it is my operating budget say
it's $1
million 70% of that operating budget is
going to be dedicated to EMS because
that's what we do 70% of the time the
other 30% of the time is dedicated to
something else that's a very simplistic
way of putting it but it's it's it's
really very accurate when you get into
the numbers um and I don't I don't need
an actual company to come in and
determine to me what the cost of my
service is it's very plain to me it's
very plain to my fire Commissioners the
board of fire Commissioners who I answer
to um what the cost of service
is at the same time so we develop a rate
and our rates are adjusted annually due
to what are cost our cost of service is
for that the year two years prior
because uh because of our audit and uh
Gathering numbers everything our rates
are set on what happened like my 2025
rates are because of what happened in
so we use our we have an auditing firm
come in every year to make sure we're
doing everything appropriately looking
at the budget making sure the numbers
are exact the number of transports the
types of transports the non- transports
so we look at all of that we look at the
depreciation of the vehicles the
equipment the depreciation of the
buildings which in my case my building
has no more depreciation because it's uh
was built in 1867 so you can't
depreciate we're really not taking
testimony here you got you got to to
your point so the point
is the taxpayers of my fire district are
supplementing Medicare and Medicaid
right now but they're also supplementing
if 316 passes they will also be
supplementing private insurance so you
say the 200 203 is too low it's way too
low I I think 375 is too so you think
the actual areial we spent all this
money doing is number numbers are wrong
their n their numbers are there's a lot
of problems with that study from my
point of view
they eliminated the 12 highest cost
providers in that service but didn't
eliminate the 12 lowest cost providers
in the service in their study because D
bellur looked funny because it had a
long tail from what I understand and I
didn't attend that part of the meeting
because I had another meeting on trying
to replace the fire station so I saw
some of so you would rather us just go
out and do another study again not pass
anything no well I'd rather you do let
me do what I want doing now and make the
insurance this is my I but at the same
time I do not want to be balanced
billing balance billing is an
administrative headache but it's a
reality of what we have to do to um be
accountable to my tax what's the mix
between balance billing and what you
charge your taxpayers I'm s I'm sorry I
didn't hear your question well how much
terms of the dollar amounts that you're
getting from your tax like I I we spent
$336,000 in my town budget so I assume
Jaffrey is going to be about the same so
so as compared to tilon in sounds like
you were two towns also yes okay so so
you're very much similar to our
situation so we're a fire district so uh
the ambulance service is part of the
fire department right so you had to
segment that off somehow so my operating
budget uh well the proposed operating
budget last year uh no it was the past
operating budget was 3.55 5
million 7% of that for me to get compare
mine to you I have to add back my fire
department and and and amb and uh
jaffre's fire department to get the
number that to match up the way you guys
do your number you could do it that way
or you could subtract that 70% of my
business is EMS so you take my 3.55
million and just use 70% of that as your
cost but for EMS but that's a number you
just picked out of the air 70% no that's
what my EMS services
are okay so okay 70% of my business is
EMS got it that's based on your records
excuse me that's based on your records
yes ma'am thank you okay all right we
got we got to try to get to a solution
here um the the other thing is uh I I
was just thinking that maybe I would not
want to kill 725 that I would want to
retain that in case case this whole
thing implodes when we get to committee
a conference that at least we have
another bill we can introduce for next
year and chairman you mentioned uh you
just you just mentioned before that uh I
don't know where you got the comment
from but you did mention that I know
that Senate might be more willing to
pass 725 vers 316 so and you have done
quite good du deligence on 316 so why
don't you combine those two I mean the
only difference you can't combine it
because they're both opposite no but but
combining what I meant is that in 316
you have done very good due diligence to
put audit every two years and all those
good things right the only difference in
the number is 200% versus 3 325 see
that's the funny thing about 316 the
200% is not in the bill the bill the
bill is based upon the
report so that's not even they not so
that's that's not even known then so
it's it's it's based upon the analysis
and and the calculated analysis so I
that's just just stick with at this
point I now we will not make the motion
of inexpedient on 725 um I would like to
make that motion to be retained so we
retain that bill for both and and then
for 316 obviously I'm I'm hoping for an
not to pass and I realize that some of
you might want to vote
now yeah I
comments no no I mean something is
better than nothing
okay
okay all right so um I move on um on
retain that mean we'll we'll discuss
this again in January means we'll
discuss it in September after we' seen
what happened what happens to 316 yeah
why don't you let both the bills go
together at the same time you're no no
we're not going to retain we're going to
pass something no both let we don't pass
to no you you you have a you have you
choose a policy and you stick to it okay
so our the bill we want to go with is I
would like to retain
um are we ready is is the question
clear okay all those in favor of
retaining
725 1 2 3 4 5 6 seven eight
right because Brian's here so it's got
retain okay so that no it's really not
it's really not the problem is I can't
see people that's my problem okay so uh
and that was hunt and second by
representative burrow
okay
now
316 um I will
move
call oh okay that's fine y okay
pass second by representative
Burrows any discussion on the motion of
ought to
pass all those in favor raise raise your
hand but we can have something right
four no we don't
she that's
something yes teria oh you got set no
Burrows is not on it it's spear oh okay
that was my
mistake okay so the most
be okay so what was the the vote is uh
the motion is ought to pass on 316 so
one two three four
five
opposed Theos those who POS one
two okay five to two all right I got it
right this
transparency
right all right what do we want to do
with this
one
705 okay so when did we just got this I
just got this you just got this so Keith
has an has has another amendment have
you guys yes we drafted it for you've
seen this yes we drafted it
Hees okay so what are we doing with this
this is what we would recommend and we
understand it's approved by
representative Ammon yes and um if you
would like me to explain the amendment
okay so but but I obviously I have it
who's for who wrote this the
yeah we did okay okay going to pass okay
it
okay as you will
recall this bill originally was uh for
the purpose of taking the Federal
Regulation on transparency and coverage
which requires Health carriers to post
their negotiated rates with healthc care
providers and put it in state law and
the
other uh special thing that the bill
does did originally was to require that
the information be put in a uniform
format so that uh the department would
have access to the information in a
uniform format and could put out
information to the public allowing
people to make comparisons between
prices um what happened and there was a
push back from Health carriers on having
to put the data that they now post in a
uniform
format what has happened since then is
um that the president has issued an
executive order this was it's only about
2 weeks old
requiring that very same thing that the
um the price information be put in a
uniform format and that the three
federal agencies that are responsible
for writing the regulation revise their
guidance to require the uniform format
so that people can make that those
comparisons so this amendment recognizes
the existence of the Federal Executive
Order and the fact that it requires the
agencies to amend their guidance within
90 days and it says that the um
Insurance
Department's standard for uniform format
has to be consistent with the new
federal
guidance
so yes so this is not official Amendment
yes which is what I I Char was my charge
was that I I really didn't want to
reinvent the wheel so that that what we
Tuesday because by next Tuesday we'll
up okay any other questions to the
committee
members get off easy Alex thank
you okay so um I assume we're all okay
with with this and and we'll have that
Amendment
transparency oh
right um I passed out a few of you that
rest if you already if you already have
one uh please don't take another one
because I think I have just enough for
for everybody but representing Harvard
Pilgrim Healthcare uh again the state's
not for profit health insurance company
and we had some strong objections to uh
the bill in part because and and the
department is right the the overall
situation is the feds have required uh
data reporting um and that did not go
well because they did not specify
exactly how it was supposed to be
reported so everybody's doing something
different so the data is fairly useless
for the stated purpose of allowing
people to compare uh and see what's
going on um so uh our L one of our big
concerns certainly was the amount of
time and effort it took and money to
contract with companies to actually do
this thing for the federal side uh why
do we would want to recreate that and go
through that whole process again when
why can't they just fix it on the
federal side and make it so that the
stuff is transparent so that's a copy of
the third page I think of the
president's executive order um and the I
think I put a little stars on the
sections that are they're applicable
basically the president has told the uh
three cabinet secretaries uh get
together in 90 days figures out how to
fix us uh and especially I think
paragraph sub paragraph B there says
find a standardized way uh so people can
do what we want them to do so if the
federal data is there it basically
requires us to to post on our website or
put a link it's a huge file I think I
mentioned the other day how many
hundreds of megabytes it was uh but we
put a link to it on our um website as
all carriers will have to so rather than
have us do something to create something
special for the Department why can't the
department just use that data assuming
that everybody's going to be using the
same format from now on so uh our
suggestion is I know you don't want to
retain bills I was thinking retain the
bill uh see what happens after 90 days
see what recommendations they have um
rather than go through all this really a
lot of extra work and um you know we
basically Harvard Pilgrim has to
contract uh these Services out so it's
not like we have people sitting around
in this non- Excel spreadsheet now this
is this is a lot of work and I think at
the public hearing somebody said well
they have people called software
engineers and I would say yes I know I'm
one I have a degree in computer science
I started a software company grew it to
the Inc 500 list sold thousands of
copies of software all over the country
um this is not a trivial matter and so
we think get the federal system fixed so
we don't have to reinvent the wheel at
the state side thank
you
okay representative Gibbs thank you um
relative to the uh executive order um
can this be done in 90 days well it's uh
we'll see that's I think the directive
is come back to me within 90 days and
say okay how do we fix this uh how do we
fix this at the federal level this all
started with an executive order from I
believe President Trump the first time
that put all this together and clearly
it wasn't specific enough so he's
basically saying to his people go back
figure out how to fix it and come back
and tell me and then we'll fix it so
okay but the problem with retaining
means we would not have anything P we
can't pass anything until
January right so would we get in trouble
if there was a federal plan and we
didn't have a state plan until next June
there's no requirement to have a state
plan at all the feds require the
insurance carrier to provide this data
so why why are we passing legislation
why why well yeah I mean we would not be
disappointed if the bill got killed but
we you know we appreciate we we do
understand and agree in concept what the
department is looking to do is is get
data you're you're you're you're making
it too easy for me what why I guess let
me ask the department is there a
rational reason why we need to have a
state law well it's
important I I should have had you over
here
Alex okay um it's important that the
carriers have a legal obligation to
provide us accurate data but that's a
federal is this but if this is a federal
right law it's a federal La they have
their own consequences I know they don't
have you're so the licenses you're
looking at John Hunt's rule of licensure
we is a big piece of this in state and
so you want to be able to take that you
want to be able to tell them they' been
get feds have not been good on data
enforcement we are good at it
and I
think traditionally CMS has deferred to
the states to enforce this and um where
we have the chiz that we have a whole
department or division dedicated to data
analytics there's a lot of great data
here we would like to be able to use it
but in order to do that we need to
standardize the for what's the effective
dat oh P passage oh great well I mean
the proposed legislation is really just
giving us can we say the Act will take
effect upon passage of the federal
legislation sure sure that could be a
condition how about
that does that sound better
Pete I think that makes him
happy you don't you don't think that'll
work Paul well why don't you just say
that uh the New Hampshire license
insurance carrier shall comply with this
federal law uh rather than say because
this is still gives the department the
ability to make their own format and we
have to go through the whole thing again
we'll tell you what our format is it'll
be in Federal law what the format is
then you can go to the data and get it
yourself uh and then we don't have to
wheel theal La well is in this no I
wasn't saying follow it I was saying
upon that when was the effective date oh
um all right
egg so this legislation is not um
dictating any specific format it doesn't
necessarily give us the ability to
require any kind of format what we're
trying to do is get a standardized
format just like the federal government
so that we can actually use this data as
intended what we're planning on doing is
paying backing off of whatever the feds
come up with we just want the ability to
enforce it and that's why we've brought
this legislation is to make sure that we
have everything we need to enforce the
transparency and coverage Provisions
that CMS is expecting us to enforce and
so that we can actually start using this
purpose and that's what this amendment
is it's it's amending the bill to align
with the uh Federal Executive Order okay
yeah some of it is you in terms of name
stuff so I know the original bill and I
didn't look for this in the amendment um
but the original Bill allow the
commissioner to establish what the
format should be um and whether that's
changed in the amendment I'm not sure is
that in here Alex so says be consistent
with the feral Federal hasent with
Federal
P this is a chicken in the egg so does
we and my Specialists on this have have
concerns about time frame I think we
share similar concerns progr also sort
of the question of why it's needed but
we have not a chance only of the
department so I think my general concern
is around timing and amount of
have to the federal rules they come out
and the state as well yes so I my fear
is that the feds may take forever to get
it
done that's my but we don't live in a
world we have you know we have to do one
thing for the federal government and
then do something slightly different for
a reason that's unknown to me for the
state and I guess we're questioning the
urgency whoever's speaking please speak
you I guess so sorry about that Sabrina
dlab from Anthem um again we got this
yesterday and so I just got feedback
from my team so I was trying to chat
with the department but it's a little
bit rushed um so what I've gleaned from
our specialist is there's concern around
the timing and how much time we would
have to once the federal requirements
come out then comply with state law and
I guess we share Harvard pilgram sort of
general questions around the urgency of
why this is needed right now so we would
agree with
retaining and I think our team would
also not be sad if the bill went away
but trying to be collaborative so so
concerns and from the Department's
perspective we're trying to advance the
whole rationale behind transparency and
coverage and actually get that
transparency out there in order to do
that we need these changes so that we
can actually use the
data so one other thing I'm just looking
at the email from our team if I could um
it says the from the amendment
Provisions would be applicable for plan
years beginning onor after 1126 this is
an aggressive timeline uh it's unclear
Federal guidance will be finalized by
then and and they said at the very least
we need a reasonable Runway from the
date of finalized Federal guidance at
least 6 months from the date final
regulations are issued perhaps longer so
that's just I would say that's the
problem with the retaining is that
retaining means you this wouldn't become
law until at best next May so then we're
in a world where we're complying with
state requirements on this issue and
then Federal Regulations are updated and
we're then complying with those it's
just
it it is a lift and I think I don't
quite see the reason
for needing to get a state law through
on this at this moment so again we did
not have a lot of time to process we've
been talking in the department I'm not
trying to you know say bades we haven't
had a lot time to look at the amendment
my saying the effective date should be
when the Act take takes effect for
federally seems like the right answer
the federal statute requiring this has
been an effect for a while this is
really just the guidance in how you're
putting together the I got that isn't
there effective where the feds say that
they expect someone to be in compliance
with their statute depending on how they
do it they could issue it in guidance
and there's not necessarily um rules go
we like guidance right don't we like and
we'd be happy to proceed that way if um
you guys think it's appropriate we can
issue our guidance as well because these
are
laws that are already on the books we're
really just trying to get some
consistency in the way it's
being compiled that what the underlying
data requirements are not changing it's
just the way that they're being compiled
disclosed it's a formatting issue and
format Jason feel free to come up if you
thank you Mr Shar just a quick moment uh
Jason I a director of Health Economics
New Hampshire insurance department I
work with the data the claims data
indeed with the hospital price
transparency data and the transparency
and coverage data two different domains
from two different actors I just wanted
to comment the carriers we shared this
important legislative Endeavor with the
carriers in late summer and have had
they've had ample time um to review that
we're not really hearing that much
response from them until just recently
which concerns me but um the urgency
part I just wanted to address this is
part of 2020 2020 Consolidated
Appropriations act and it's 2025 now and
there is no State thus far who's made
any use of the insurers transparency and
coverage data it's a different story
compared to the same legislation at the
same time for the hospital transparency
and there's a reason why and it has to
do with the the lack of the guidance or
the the structure of the guidance for
the formatting and so what a shame to
have rendered such important data for
policy makers and our citizens to
understand how much things cost for
their health care still not knowing
because of a formatting issue so I the
last thing I just wanted to comment on
is the marginal cost of being compliant
with the same standard that the federal
government has essentially um provided
for and even with the the new standards
the amendment provides that the state
law will follow along with that so
there'll be no new cost incurred because
of new new standardization rather the
fact that these data sets are already
framed the the fixed cost of that
endeavor is almost already endured and
so now it's just the variable cost which
is the small marginal cost so I just
didn't want the overstatement of the
cost burden to to be the lasting message
because I don't agree with that this is
an important Endeavor for my role at the
department the Department's transparency
work for which we have a longstanding
tenure for doing that and now we we've
been pioneers of that pioneers and it's
still not known to our consumers how
much I got I got I I have now resolved
it for myself so here's my
the provisions of this subdivision apply
for plan years beginning on or after
January 1 of
2026 so even if we left in this language
that is that the date say it's it takes
effect upon
passage nothing is really happening yet
until January 1 in where the data is now
being uploaded has to be you got to be
preparing to add data January 1st so
that means in the meantime you know
you're unless you're going to put in
pre- dat before the January one um I
guess I'm not really worried about the
effective date anymore because the the
whole thing is January 1 so all they're
saying is is that you you've got to take
you know the companies I'm looking at
you three
right that you're you take you got to do
get your systems in place how you're
going to download the data what you're
going to do with it but you don't have
to do anything until January 1
anyways all you have to do is be ready
wrong okay let's pretend like let's just
go with this idea and then
um and if you come up with something
better you can take it up with the
Senate
president yeah at this point I you know
I I can't I don't want to belabor this
anymore this is this is this is too
painful and I think that yeah right well
compared to what we've been through
already Yes we just to say is you know
when you pick your poison when's the
right day when right that the at the end
of the day the purpose is both the
federal and yours is is that it's
supposed to be ready to go January
1 that's what it says here to me I mean
that's what I see the provision so I
think we'll leave it just as it
OLS last chance any other changes other
than
I'll give you something to do to talk to
the senate about it I'm sure they want
to hear hear all these
issues okay I think we're done with
Healthcare
right
okay thank you all very much now we're
on to
496 uh no because we don't have an amend
Amendment We Will We Will vote be taking
this up on
Tuesday with an official
Amendment okay uh so 496 info liquor
stores this we just did this bu do
anybody really feel we need revisit this
issue
again okay so who's G who would like to
make the
right Walsh second by
motion6
what
time what I represented wals did did
thank you right you're you're still on
it because otherwise represented miles
will do it if you want to give
one okay it uh the motion is itl
representative walls second by
representative Burrows of uh 496 any
discussion on the motion see none all
those in favor raise their hand 1 2 3
four five six and how many people are on
yeah who's on this this
is
W yeah
you
got okay okay all right so that that was
representative oh what do the vote to
come out to be uh we are seven seven to
zip
yep well all I know is that all seven
people are in the room so I'm just going
to count
them at this
point this is why that's why they have a
house clerk you know because you can't
expect the speaker to count
okay all right next one is
529 oh this make a motion this is the
yeah okay um so yeah I actually was
talking to the sponsor and I suggested
just because this needs to be amended
and it hasn't been that hasn't been done
we haven't had a chance to do it no um
could we retain it and come back to it
in the fall and it definitely would work
on it because I'm interested in this but
um I'm always good for retaining okay
cuz it it each piece is going to take a
lot of takes some work we don't have
time to do it before contemplation MH so
actually with the the hour ones we
already did that and the Senate stuck it
in our face so well we know that that's
where fun goes to die but that doesn't
mean we shouldn't do it
again and then I have to say Mike is
that the problem with the hours ones is
in you know your testimony you know that
who who Who's going to find the people
to do this that's not our problem and
certainly the owner doesn't have to stay
open
late thanks for
sharing okay so we're going to retain
the motion is to retain uh any
discussion on the motion all those in
favor raise your hand one two three four
five
six 7
Z pris you right
you're who was
my it wasn't pus okay walls post myself
yeah so all seven
okay all
right okay next is the tavern
Bill have anyone
assigned oh to the retain is is
C and then second by
yes
uh we were supposed to get an amendment
weren't
we okay here it
is he has it I got it right here in my
pause
okay so uh think it's probably not going
give there we
[Music]
okay so the we start out with um Roman
numeral
one the commission May issue a Tavern
license in any town which has voted to
accept the
provisions now reason why this is
important is because we're going to be
lifting this concept and put it in other
places
so what are you asking me did it go down
this way yeah yeah everybody everybody's
okay and then the rest of the language
there's nothing in here about
cost I'm not seeing Oh with the the
license dollar amount of the license
wasn't there going to be something like
you were going to do I I think I pulled
the number out of out of the air didn't
I 6400 yeah yeah so what happened where
where that would that we didn't put it
in this amendment this isn't the one I
submitted oh this is not this is the
first one that o that um OS drafted okay
rut
R so um did I did I forward you anything
so
all right well we're gonna take this up
week
six correct so the the number one the
6635 is if the town allows liquor
licenses
so that's standard in all liquor license
um rsas because that just says the town
is going to allow alcohol to be sold in
their Town what the committee had
requested last time was the local option
where the town would have to vote to
allow a Tavern license in the town much
like Kino so it mirors The Kino language
that they would have to put it on the
ballad vote to allow a Tavern license to
be accepted in the town before we could
accept an application for a Tavern
license in the the town but that first
line is just saying alcohol can be sold
in the town but isn't that what this
says no this is specific to the town in
general is going to allow any type of
liquor
license
ACS
oh
right obviously we're going to have to
come back to this um can you make sure
Kristen has the correct one so we can
get that to LOLs and take a but don't go
anywhere please do not
leave okay this is the 18th as
well
okay all right next one is uh social
districts did we have an amendment for
467 now
right it was a
typo ke Keo was still in it okay so you
did so so I had we had some we had the
language from the original bill
and you're saying there was just one
little typo that we needed to
correct that was our understanding I
don't know if he if um the
representative had made additional
changes to
that there it is
that's
people
said
e
um
okay didn't do 467 yet the social
districts did we do we do we have the
amendment on the no there was no
amendment was there no 467 we need a on
467 did we have any
mistake is that the one with the keynote
yeah okay so this one has a little
one-word problem so we're GNA have to
take that up on Tuesday so on page two
line five it has the word Keno
is6
467 that's the
word and then and then 276 had the same
word problem is that what happened no no
the T um 276 referred to the wrong the T
had just the wrong bill right
okay okay so now right so now we're down
to
565 I'll move that
well so we're having a little bit of
disagreement on this
bill
um um because I my memory was we were
that
that that if you were going to sign
someone in you had they had to be a
relative that's my memory you discussed
family family or a
relative um obviously the commission is
pointing out that that somewhat
enforceable problem we said family
members oh so I did
okay the person who is and a family
member unquote family
member
um yeah so I I think that's how we left
it unfortunately is that we were going
to do family member but where we going
to change family member to unless it it
old and let's who has sign
in the minor family member minor or
miners into the club and listed their
age
family okay so we we do
have an opposite opinion from our former
bill yeah you can sit over here no you
guys stay right
there in the old days we used to just
you know hold together but it's all
so thank you for allowing me to speak
introduce yourself Jane bolier former
State
Rep um sorry about the gum but anyway um
the reason why you do not want children
into a social club number one they watch
their parents drink all night long
because often times when people go to
Social Clubs they are all night and
their kids kids are there with them all
night and then they drive home drunk
with their kids another reason smoking
you don't want a child in a room full of
smoke for two or three
hours and this is very personal for me
my daughter is an alcoholic her father
used to take her to Social Clubs when
she was 6 years old seven8 nine 10 we
were divorced at the time I didn't know
this until just
recently so um she would drink at the
club
because her father wanted her drunk um
and they were drinking so it's
absolutely ridiculous that you would
allow a child to be in a social club
another reason there's no you don't have
to eat there because there's no food
oftentimes so it's dangerous for the
child
and no there's no good reason to have
someone six seven eight years old which
they could be reading this bill in a
social club watching their parents drink
and smoke and then driving home with
them drunk that's absolutely no not
being responsible as a state legislator
to pass this bill so please
don't thank you so you can smoke in
these
conditions were
CL but then they said persons not with
standing so persons under the age of 21
shall be allowed in renovable rooms
approved by the commission when beverage
spell so they're raising the
age
in these side rooms like you're saying
the ballrooms right no those are already
those aren't age restricted at the
moment so in a social club you have the
canteen the canteen is the members only
portion of the
club um that is remember you have to be
um is it 21 I think it's eight I think
it's 18 right now unless or you're
accompanied by uh no sorry no parent so
18 signed in by a member um there are
function Halls that are associated with
these clubs the function Halls are not
age restricted they are separate from
the canteen those would be the halls or
the rooms that the public can rent or
the um Social Club could host an event
in if they wanted to serve alcohol at
those events then they request a
supplemental license from us to allow
alcohol service in those rooms so
sometimes there are parties with alcohol
there sometimes there or not um we see a
host of things such as celebrations of
life baby showers wedding showers again
some have they use the supplemental
license for some they do not but the
canteen itself is currently the age
restricted portion of the club this
would allow underage um people or miners
into the canteen members only area of
the
club right because it well it says
rentable rooms approved by the
commission so that's what you're talking
about is the small rooms isn't it that's
that's the the function rooms yeah
they're they're talking about raising
the age to 21 from 18 and I thought that
was open to anybody so I'm I'm totally
of1 yeah on that one they're going the
opposite way yeah they're already
only
right and the the rentable rooms are per
are allowing persons under the age of 18
are allowed in rentable rooms that's the
statute as it is right now
okay all right there it is Sir without a
parent or Guardian present at such times
now the agent shall be allowed in the
rentable rooms and they're moving it
from 18 to 21 so that is
say well that's what I'm saying so
understand why this paragraphs in the
stat anyways in the rentable rooms
because the first paragraph sets the age
restriction for the canteen for any room
the first section is for any
room correct second section is the
rentable
rooms so without a parent or Guardian
present so that allows individuals under
the age of 18 to be in rentable rooms
even if there's a supplemental license
without a parent or Guardian right okay
so there's your family member quote we
just put parent or Guardian present
because assuming that's enforceable
phrase
okay
um ask what what's the uh liquor
commission's Take On The Spill do you
support it neutral they want us to kill
it what are you kidding then let's kill
it
I told L we would or at least retain it
it they can do that in the rentable
rooms they can't do that in the canteen
so where that was what that was the that
was the story yeah that was the
story so because I have to I visualized
you know our BMW we have it's got It's
really got two big actually has three
rooms there has a smaller room that's
right by the door you know and then you
have the next the big room where they do
the meat auction and uh and then that
has a bar in it and also it has
hamburgers and hot dogs so that would be
the rentable room that's the rentable
room even the other room that other room
is a rent room it just doesn't have a
bar in it that you know and then and
then you go behind the big you know
famous doors and now you're into the
canteen the canteen which is the members
only age restricted member restricted
so maybe there particular VFW doesn't
have that could be I thought the sponsor
was a member of a social
club so it just could be the setup floor
the floor plan of that particular Social
Club all right I will schedule this for
military well the military yes said to
the military uh but is in the military
does not need to be accompanied by a
person 21 years or older
person who is under 21 Old but is in the
military does not need to be accompanied
by a person 21 over does that mean they
don't get have to be signed in well well
currently persons it's 18 plus right now
in the canteen right cu no person under
the age of 18 right so if they're in the
military in their 18 19 or 20 they can
already get in right was I'm saying cuz
no well a lot of them a lot of them have
actually ban smoking a lot of them have
baned
smoking we're just trying to figure out
what to do with this bill can we retain
it all right we'll just retain it I'll
moves to retain seconded uh by
representative
burough there's too much verbage in
here okay any uh any discussion on the
motion all those in favor say I I 1 two
three four five six seven zip all seven
plans for next week so next plan so next
week we will Tuesday we'll have
subcommittees and then Wednesday I'll
try to what I'll try to do is schedule
everything into Tuesday morning and that
way if there's any hang hiccups we can
do Tuesday afternoon we we'll take
you'll get it done but Wednesday morning
is the is we're going to exec them all
Tuesday Wednesday Yeah Tuesday Wednesday
and then th
Wednesday morning and that technically
leads us Wednesday afternoon if we're
crash so Tuesday Tuesday will be
subcommittees Wednesday morning's exec
session so if you're not going to be
able to make the Wednesday morning exec
session please let us know as soon as
possible so we everybody can be replaced
okay